l'exemple de le
P pleine puissance en 2035 donc sur les
10 prochaines années on pourrait baisser
10 % l'économie d'énergie dans le dans
le bâtiment donc les solutions
techniques existent dans le bâtiment je
crois que c'est toujours très important
de garder à l'esprit le réservoir
d'énergie que représente le bâtiment
changer les systèmes de chauffage
n'apporte pas du confort thermique à
l'occupant ne baisse pas la facture
énergétique ça en change l'origine mais
il faut apporter du confort aux
habitants confort thermique et confort
sur leur facture pour être accompagné et
que la transition énergétique soit
socialement acceptable par ailleurs et
ce sera l'essentiel de mon propos nous
allons fondamentalement manquer de
beaucoup d'énergie et d'énergie
décarbonée en France en Europe pour les
prochaines années donc je pense que
c'est très très très important de
focaliser également tous les efforts qui
sont possibles dans l'efficacité énerg
Energétique de l'enveloppe du bâtimement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que avec une bonne enveloppe l'isolation
totale du bâtiment vous divisez par 6 ou
se la consommation énergétique d'un
bâtiment vous voyez que la solution
technique existe dans le bâtiment et que
ça peut être un réservoir fantastique
d'économie d'énergie avant même de se
préoccuper de la substitution de la
source d'énergie donc voilà je pense que
c'est important d'avoir ce propuminaire
parce que nous c'est notre métier que
d'apporter des solutions à la fois
construction neuve on parle de
construction son légère il y a des modes
constructifs qui permettent de diviser
par deux le poids des matériaux et donc
la teneur en CO2 des matériaux et puis
naturellement vous l'avez évoqué madame
la Présidente le marché de la rénovation
qui dans le monde représente 50 % de
notre activité et dans la rénovation
rénovation d'une maison individuelle en
France avec une trentaine de produits
avec 250 € par mètre carré vous pouvez
diviser par 5 ou 6 la facture
énergétique de la maison et ensuite
ayant
substitué cette facture avec une facture
moindre vous avz avez baissé la
consommation énergétique vous avez
apporté du confort thermique et vous
pouvez éventuellement sur une pompe à
chaleur qui ne serait pas
surdimensionnée à ce moment-là
substituer la source d'énergie quand on
regarde d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
solutions pour le bâtiment de
saint-gobin notre dynamique interne
c'est de minimiser notre empreinte
industrielle en terme d'émission de CO2
et de maximiser l'impact de nos
solutions puisque vous savez que le
monde de la construction dans l'ensemble
du globe représente à peu près 40 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un/art
de ça c'est la fabrication des matériaux
leur distribution et la l'érection du
bâtiment les 3/4 c'est la vie du
bâtiment l'air conditionné l'énergie
qu'on dépense quand on apporte des
solutions pour la rénovation et pour la
construction durable on peut éviter 1,3
milliards de tonnes de CO2 dans la durée
de vie du bâtiment donc les solution que
saint-gomin met en œuvre évite 1,3
milliards de tonnes de CO2 dans la durée
de vie du bâtiment donc c'est 40 fois
notre empruninte de CO2 scope 1 2 et 3
et c'est l'équivalent des émissions
annuelles de la France de l'Allemagne et
du Royaume-Uni réunies donc voilà il y a
un sujet très important dans le monde de
la construction d'efficacité énergétique
d'efficacité sur les émissions de CO2 et
de réservoir d'énergie puisque nous
voyons à quel point nous manquons
d'énergie quel qu'en soit la source
décarboné ou pas décarboné puisque on
achète encore énormément de gaz à
l'étranger alors maintenant passons aux
enjeux de décarbonation des procédés de
de saint-obin pour rappel no nos
principaux procédés c'est la production
de verre plat pour le bâtiment pour
l'automobile la production de laine
minérale euh laine de verre laine de
roche les matériaux de d'isolation la
production de plaques de plâtre euh
plaqueau c'est notre marque générique
isovt en france la production de
matériaux céramiques tous ces procédés
sont intensifs en énergie le groupe
consomme à peu près 40 tawh d'énergie
dans le monde c'est en électricité et le
reste en gaz nous avons 4 taw en France
c'est un d'électricité et le solde donc
tris en en gaz not notre facture
énergétique elle a triplé dans l'espace
de de 2 ans elle est de 3 milliards
d'euros ça représente 15 % grosso modo
de nos coûts industriels alors ça va
jusqu'à 30 % quand on regarde la
fabrication de verre plat 15 % de nos
coûts industriels en Europe et c'est le
tiers de ça aux États-Unis puisque
l'énergie aux États-Unis est beaucoup
beaucoup moins cherre j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure donc vous comprenez bien
que nous devons être très attentif sur à
la fois nos consommations en énergie et
naturellement nous engager vers une
empreinte carbone plus faible avec un
travail sur
l'énergie nous avons aussi tout un tas
d'autres activités qui elles sont moins
énergivor évidemment des activités
industrielles moins intensifs dans leurs
procédés et puis tout un tas d'activités
de négo de matériaux vous qui êtes sur
tout le territoire français vous savez
que nous avons 2000 points de négoces de
matériaux où précisément nous formons
les artisans nous nous engageons pour
avoir des générations d'artisans
nouvelles pour répondre à tous les
besoins qu'on connaît dans le bâtiment
aujourd'hui alors nous nous sommes
engagés en 2019 sur une trajectoire de
neutralité carbone à horizon
2050 c'est un engagement qui a été
validé par l'organisation internationale
qui est celle de référence la plus la
plus reconnue sur ce domaine là qui
s'appelle science based target
initiative ça veut dire que nous allons
réduire d'au moins 90 % nos émissions
directes dans notre chaîne de valeur par
rapport à une année de référence de 2017
et puis développer des solutions de
séquestration des émissions euh
résiduel à ce stade nous n'avons pas
inclus de compensation financière de ces
émissions dans notre feuille de route ça
c'est 2050 vous pourriez vous dire 2050
pour saint-gobin c'est très loin bonoît
Bazin ne sera pas là mais en fait c'est
pas ça la réalité parce que notre
réalité c'est que une usine de verre
plat dure 20 ans avant de la
reconstruire de reconstruire le four
donc pour qu'une usine de verre plat
soit neutre en carbone en 2050 il faut
qu'elle soit prête en 2030 une usine de
verre plat c'est 150 millions
d'investissements donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut un pilote industriel en 2025
donc vous voyez bien que pour nous c'est
pas un horizon qui est loin vous
connaissez l'histoire de saint-gobin on
se projette autant qu'on peut toujours
sur le temps long mais le temps long de
2050 pour nous c'est déjà un temps très
court puisque 2025 ça veut dire des
pilotes industriels pour qu'on puisse
engager 150 millions d'investissements
en 2030 sur des usines qui seront bas
carbone donc on y travaille et on s'est
d'ailleurs défini une étape
intermédiaire sur notre feuille de route
de décarbonation à horizon 2030 avec
l'engagement de réduire de 33 % VX
émissions dites de scope 1 et 2 en 2030
par rapport à la la base de 2017 alors
la bonne nouvelle c'est que en 2022 nous
avons déjà réduit de 27 % ces émissions
par rapport à 2017 donc on est plutôt en
avance par rapport à cette feuille de
route de 2030 et tout ça à périmètre
total de saint-gobin donc saint-gobin a
cru en chiffre d'affaires nous avons
fait des acquisitions nous avons
développé des nouvelles usines donc
quand je rapporte les émissions de CO2
dans un € de chiff d'affaires de Sabin
en 2022 c'est - 42 % par rapport à 2017
donc ça veut dire que c'est possible de
faire de la croissance tout en étant
respectueux de l'environ puisque c'est
quand même une baisse de 42 % de la
teneur de l'intensité carbone dans un
euro de chiffreaffair de saint-bin en
scope 1 et 2 par rapport à 2017 et c'est
encore plus en terme de résultat puisque
madame la Président vous avez eu
l'amabilité de rappeler que nous avons
eu des bonnes trajectoires de résultats
c'est ins 57 % par rapport à nos
résultats donc à la fois croissance et
croissance rentable alors comment
travaillons-nous sur ces réductions
d'émissions il faut savoir que 2030
comme j'ai dit c'est demain matin pour
nous il y aura pas de d'innovation de
rupture au plan technologique à large
échelle d'ici là donc on se doit de
travailler sur une panoplie de de
domaine des travaux sur l'excellence
opérationnelle des travaux sur
l'efficacité excellence opérationnelle
ça veut dire améliorer les rendement
réduire les déchets toutes les petits
détails qui font la vie d'une usine une
usine de ver plat il y a 9000 capteurs
de mesures de température de pression
d'épaisseur à tous les endroits de la
ligne de fabrication donc c'est ça qui
nous permet petit à petit d'optimiser
nos nos processus c'est naturellement
l'efficacité énergétique de nos de nos
procédés avec tout un tas de sujet de
récupération de chaleur nous avons aussi
pas mal d'échanges avec récupération de
chaleur ça peut être utilisé aussi pour
du chauffage urbain avec un un bon appui
de l'Adème sur un certain nombre de de
projets c'est aussi un gros travail sur
le contenu recyclé de nos produits un
exemple quand on remplace une tonne de
sable pour fabriquer du verre à partir
de de matière vierge par une tonne de
verre recyclé on on divise par tris
quasiment les émissions de CO2 parce que
vous avez déjà fabriqué la matrice
verrière donc vous n'avez plus à
refondre le sable en partant en amont
donc c'est 350 kg de CO2 économisé quand
on prend du verre recyclé donc j'
reviendrai parce que un des enjeux très
importants sur les sujets d'économie
circulaire c'est naturellement toutes
les boucles de les filières de recyclage
et comment on capte les fenêtres en
France ou ou ailleurs pour améliorer ce
recyclage un exemple notre isolation
laine de verre laine minérale nous avons
60 70 % de matière recyclé dans la laine
de verre en France 88 % dans une usine
auawa au Canada donc c'est possible
d'avancer sur l'économie
circulaire 3è sujet au-delà de
l'excellence opérationnelle l'efficacité
énergne de nos process le contenu
recyclé de nos produit c'est avoir accès
à de l'électricité
décarbonée c'est aussi j'y reviendrai
c'est aussi un enjeu d'avoir accès à de
l'énergie renouvelableénergie solaire
sur nos sites donc nous avons été est
assez précurseur depuis maintenant 5 ans
à signé des accords pour avoir de
l'énergie éolienne de l'énergie solaire
pu on s'y prend tau plus on a la
possibilité de modérer les les coûts que
ça représente c'est aussi substituer du
gaz naturel par du biogaz par de la
biomasse nous avons par exemple une
usine en Inde qui est dans une région
avec beaucoup de d'activités agricole de
riz on récupère de l'écorce de riz on
fait des petites briquettes et toute
l'usine fonctionne avec la biomasse de
riz donc il y a beaucoup d'innovation
aussi sur les procédés ou sur les
sources d'énergie dans tous les domaines
partout dans le monde c'est aussi
beaucoup d'effort au quotidien là je
viens plus sur la partie bâtiment de
saint-gobin nous avons naturellement
pris tous les engagements dans le décret
tercière pour les surfaces de plus de de
1000 m² avec l'enregistrement des
consommations de de référence dans notre
siège à la défense nous avons réduit 12
% notre consommation d'énergie en 2022
par rapport à à 2021 on prévoit une
réduction supplémentaire de l'ordre de
15 % en 2023 par rapport à 2022 je
pourrais revenir si vous voulez sur la
façon avec laquelle on s'y prend mais là
aussi c'est un ensemble de petites
mesures qui ensuite font les les grandes
rivières alors à plus long terme nous il
nous faut déployer des nouvelles
technologies notamment pour passer des
production du gaz à l'électrique et
c'est pas si simple que ça par exemple
aujourd'hui il y a aucune usine de verre
plat qui a la capacité technique de
fonctionner avec de l'électrique parce
que vous avez besoin d'une puissance
énergétique extrêmement précise puisque
un verre plat c'est 1500 der plus ou
moins 1 degr sur une surface de 300 m²
si vous faites pas ça vous avez des
impuretés du verre alors ça ferait des
fenêtres comme autre fois mais c'est
quand même pas la tendance pour avoir un
pare-brise
automobile donc on doit basculer sur une
électrification de nos procédés ce qu'on
sait faire dans un certain nombre de
domaines ce sur quoi on travaille encore
sur le verre plat alors quelques
exemples puisque on on a beaucoup avancé
vous savez que saint-gbin a fait des
premières mondiales avec une première
production zéro carbone de verre plat en
France l'année dernière en scope 1 et 2
une première fabrication zéro carbone de
plaque de plâtre en en scope 1 et 2
également en Suède et depuis on a lancé
une première usine électrifiée de plaque
de plate la plaque de plat consomme
beaucoup de gaz parce qu'il faut
mouiller le plâtre pour faire le la pâte
comme font les les plâtriers puis
ensuite il faut la sécher pour
naturellement obtenir la résistance
mécanique on a une très grosse usine à
vos jours par exemple on est le premier
consommateur de gaz en privé en
île-de-fance donc on s'est électrifié ce
ces procédés et on a fait on a démarré
notre première usine électrique en
Norvège de plaque de plâ pourquoi en
Norvège parce que on a 30 ans de
visibilité sur de l'hydroélectricité à
un cooupt attractif en Norvège la
deuxème sera à Montréal au Canada en
2024 parce que là aussi on a hydropower
Canada qui sur un investissement de 100
millions de dollars nous subventionne 40
millions de dollars canadiens
d'électricité et de la visibilité sur de
l'hydroélectrique sur les 40 prochaines
années nous avons euh basculé sur une
usine en France avec du biogaz à àiche
dans le nord de la France c'est ça qui
nous a fait maintenant au-delà de cette
première fabrication zéro carbone une
offre commerciale bas carbone de verre
plat avec du biogaz avec 70 % de verre
recyclé nous avons fait également une
première mondiale en Allemagne de mettre
de l'hydrogène dans un four verrier de
verre plat parce qu'on pense que la
solution à terme ce sera 50 à 60 %
d'électrique dans le sol du four pour
substituer au gaz naturel et puis un
complément de 40 % qui pourrait du
biogaz ou qui pourrait de l'hydrogène et
de l'hydrogène vert si tenter que
l'hydrogène vert existe et soit à un
coût raisonnable le le jour venu on a
d'ailleurs un partenariat avec un
concurrent japonais pour faire des tests
en ce moment sur ce qui serait le
premier four verrier avec plus de 50 %
d'électricité à savoir que en en France
nos unes de laines de verre elles sont
déjà à un bas niveau en carbone
puisqueelles fonctionneent avec des des
fours électriques alors qu'est-ce que
c'est l'obstacle principal pour nous
pour basculer plus vite sur
l'électricité bah c'est avoir de
l'électricité décarboné à un prix
raisonnable et avec de la visibilité ça
n'est pas encore le cas en ce moment je
sais que le gouvernement et toutes les
parties prenantes y travaillent je vais
vous donner un exemple quand même de ce
que ça représente pour pour nous le coût
àen de l'électricité pour un gros
industriel comme saint-cobin c'est 42 €
ça ne représente pas la totalité de
notre consommation c'est l'ordre de 60 %
il y a tous les débats en cours avec EDF
est-ce que le coût à reen sera de 70 ou
de 100 € imaginons qu'il soit de 70 je
prends un cas d'école 70 € c'est déjà
une hausse de 76 % de la facture
électrique passer de 42 à 70 70 € si
vous électrifiez une usine il y a un
coût d'investissement de
l'électrification parce qu'il faut
changer même beaucoup de d'équipement
dans l'usine donc vous avez un coût
d'amortissement grosso modo de 10 € en
plus donc 70 € d'électricité ça vous
fait en fait une usine électrique à 80
€. 80 € par rapport au gaz ça ferait un
équivalent gaz de 60 € parce qu'il y a
un facteur
d'émission du gaz de grosso modo 0,2 par
mgawh donc à 100 € la tonne de CO2 100 €
que j'applique sur le gaz ça fait 20 €
donc pour avoir de l'électrique à 80 €
c'est un équivalent gaz à 60 plus le
coût de la tonne de CO2 sur le gaz 60 €
sur du gaz il faut se comparer avec le
marché américain le marché américain
ronne dans une unité qui s'appelle le
mbtu mais qui est grosso modo 3 MW
pourbtu donc 60 € du MW gaz en France
qui encore une fois fait l'équivalent du
80, 70 àen plus les 10 de coût
d'investissement c'est l'équivalent de
20 dollars ou EUR du mbtu le gaz
américain est à 3 vous voyez que un prix
Aren à 70
pour que saint-gobin électrifie son
usine et avoir de l'électricité
décarbonée c'est 7 fois plus cher que du
gaz américain alors le gaz américain
n'est pas décarboné mais quand vous êtes
sur des productions en concurrence
internationale le coût Aren de demain il
est 76 % plus cher qu'aujourd'hui et il
est 7 fois plus cher que le coût de
l'énergie américain alors je dis ça
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de focalisation récemment sur
l'IRA l'IRA pour moi qui est passé pas
mal de temps de ma vie aux États-Unis
Unis c'est la serie sur le gâteau le
gâteau c'est l'écart gigantesque
d'énergie entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis et de surcroire avec une
politique énergétique européenne qui en
terme de visibilité n'est pas concluante
puisque nous avons pas atterri sur
qu'est-ce que c'est le coût de
l'électricité en France en 2026 pour que
saint-gobin s'engage sur
l'électrification de ses processus en
France comme on l'a fait en Norvège
comme on le faire au Canada B il faut
que je sache moi quelle est la réponse
sur le coût de l'électricité en 206 en
France et d'ailleurs 2026 c'est déjà
trop tard puisque ce sont des
investissements qui prennent de ou 3 ans
mais vous voyez que nous n'avons pas
cette réponse en France ni en Europe sur
c'est quoi la politique énergétique
c'est quoi la politique du coût de
l'électricité c'est quoi l'électricité
décarbonée de demain donc c'est c'est un
enjeu très très important et un enjeu de
compétitivité un enjeu de visibilité
l'autre sujet mais qui n'est pas des
moindres et je je m'arrête là ensuite
c'est le coût et le délai d'installation
des lignes électriques
parce que certes c'est bien d'avoir la
source d'énergie mais encore faut-il
relier les différentes usines nous avons
80 usines sur les territoires en France
alors toutes ne nécessit pas des grosses
installations électriques mais il faut
être capable de relier les usines on
fait beaucoup d'investissements à dunerc
donc je comprends que der qui est à
juste titre dans la liste de priorités
de de RTE mais il faut être capable
ensuite de relier à l'électrique tous
les sites industriels français donc
voilà un petit peu l'ensemble des des
sujets et je pourrais revenir sur des
sur les gros chiffres tout à l'heure
parce que c'est quand même des enjeux
massifs si je prenais l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des uines de saint-gobin si
on devait électrifier et et et qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire en coût de de CO2
économisé nous on est sur des
investissements qui aujourd'hui serait
sur du 800 900 € la tonne de CO2 si on
devait passer à l'électrique donc c'est
quand même 8 milliards d'investissement
qu'il faudrait faire pour électrifier
les unes de cbin on fait 2 milliards
d'investissements par an vous voyez que
tout électrifié cbin dans le monde ce
serait qu fois les investissements
annuels de sa aujourd'hui si nous
passions tous nos procédés à
l'électrique c'est 900 million de
surcout en coû de fonctionnement donc ça
veut dire que on est 25 ou 30 % plus
cher qu'aujourd'hui donc si nos
concurrents ne le font pas on sort du
marché donc on électrifie mais il y a
plus d'usine il y a plus de produit donc
ce sont des enjeux quand même qui en
terme de masse on n pas le droit de
sortir du marché parce qu'on est 30 %
plus cher et faire 8 ou 9 milliards
d'investissement aujourd'hui ça n'est
pas possible en tout cas à instanté pour
autant s'engage fortement puisque cette
trajectoire de décarbonation que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure qui nous a permis
de faire de gros progrès c'est à peu
près 200 millions d'investissements
l'année dernière sur les sujets de
décarbonation de saint-gebin nous nous
sommes imposés un prix interne du
carbone depuis 2016 sans attendre qu'il
a un marché du carbone alors il était
bas autrefois il est aujourd'hui de 100
€ pour nos investissements et de 200 €
pour nos projets de recherche et
développement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que partout dans le monde quand on
a des projets d'investissement
industriel de saint-bin que ce soit en
Inde aux États-Unis en France s en Suède
on applique un coût du carbone par
exemple sur un récupérateur de chaleur
sur un four on pourrait se dire le
retour sur investissement du
récupérateur de chaleur c'est 10 ans
mais si on applique 100 € la tonne de
CO2 perdue si on n pas ce récupérateur
de chaleur le retour sur investissement
devient 4 ans et à ce moment-là on le
fait de la même façon dans les projets
projets de recherche et développement
substituer des matières très carbonées
par des matières non carbonées si elles
sont beaucoup plus cher un chercheur va
dire ça sert à rien que je travaille
dessus parce qu'on sera pas compétitif
si on applique 200 € la tonne sur la
matière carbonée en se disant dans 10
ans ce sera peut-être 200 € la tonne de
carbone et ben on va travailler sur des
reformulations de matière pour être
capable de faire du verre avec des
matières moins carboné donc voilà on a
tout un tas de travaux et et et de Cal
en interne sur des investissements sur
des coût interne du carbone sur
naturellement tous les bonus annuels et
à long terme des managers de saint-gobin
sont alignés sur cette feuille de route
de de décarbonation on a par exemple
aussi formé plus de 8000 collaborateurs
ouvriers techniciens managers et conse
administration de saint-bin à la fresque
du climat voilà il y a un engagement de
toute l'entreprise c'est assez naturel
chez sa-bin parce que encore une fois
notre raison d'être c'est making the
world better home et la construction a
un rôle considérable à jouer pour
décarboner le monde de la construction
et baisser fondamentalement les
émissions de CO2 donc c'est pas quelque
chose qui est sur le côté pour nous la
décarbonation c'est au cœur de notre
engagement vis-à-vis de nos clients et
donc c'est au cœur de notre engagement
pour nos propres procédés produits et
nos collaborateurs voilà j'espère ne pas
avoir été trop long madame la présidente
mais je m'arrête
là merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur
Général pour ce propos liminaire donc
nous allons passer à la séance
questionsréponsse donc je vous demande
néanmoins pour essayer de tenir cet
exercice d'être le plus synthétique
possible dans la question que vous posez
on va essayer de tenir les 2 minutes
dans la question et laisser à Monsieur
le Directeur Général peut-être 5 minutes
pour la réponse mais voilà donc on a
calculé il y a déjà beaucoup de nos
collègues qui se sont inscrits donc je
vais com commencer par ordre
d'inscription sur notre boucle et puis
quelques-uns qui l'ont pas fait que l'on
a noté par ailleurs donc le premier à
poser la première question est Monsieur
Jean-Claude
tissau merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général merci
d'abord pour votre propos liminire très
clairire et très technique qui nous qui
nous éclaire pas mal j'ai simplement
deux questions assez rapides assez
simples la première question posera sur
votre filière isonate spécialisé dans
dans l'isolation en fibre de bois et
plus particulièrement sur le
développement de l' de mabli qui est
dans mon département et en effet en 2020
grâce au crédit du plan de relance des
objectifs de production très ambitieux
avaient été annoncé de passage de 19000
tonnes de panneau isolant en 2021 à
42000 tonnes en 2023 alors je sais qu'un
incendie a une une nouvelle fois touché
le site mais pouvezous pouvez-vous nous
dire si les objectifs fixés ont pu être
atteints ou s'ils sont en passe d'être
atteints sur ce site particulièrement et
puis ma deuxème question portera sur les
biomatériaux utilisés pour la
construction durable depuis plusieurs
années la recherche s'intéresse au
miscantus c'est une plante qui qui de
nombreuses vertus en particulier pour la
dépollution des sols notamment et qui
peut également être transformé en parpum
pour la construction est-ce que c'est un
matériau que vous utilisez que vous
prévoyez d'utiliser et puis une dernière
question Quels sont les principaux
biomatériaux que vous
utilisez merci Jean-Claude alors je
croyais avoir été technique mais vous
l'êtes infiniment plus que moi monsieur
le sénateur c'est très bien c'est très
bien alors notre usine mabl c'est une
usine effectivement qui fait de
l'isolation à partir de fibre de bois
dans laquelle nous avons fait des
investissements complémentaires c'est en
train de progresser mais c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué que prévu un peu plus
difficile que prévu parce que nous ne
sommes pas des experts de bois et de
l'isolation fibre de bois c'est plus la
laine minérale qui se fait à partir de
sable qui se fait à partir de Lian en
sucre et cetera donc nous montons en
puissance nous allons continuer des
investissements l'an prochain parce que
on a fait un peu plus de 5 millions
d'euros d'investissement l'année
dernière et il faut continuer à monter
en puissance donc c'est un produit qui
se développe sur les biomatériaux parce
que votre votre question est large sur
les biomatériaux je pense qu'il faut
raison garder parce que les les
biomatériaux en terme de cycle de vie ne
sont pas nécessairement les meilleurs on
ne sait pas recycler de la fibre de bois
aujourd'hui donc la captation de carbone
au moment où la plante ou le bois a
grandi si vous laissez pourrir votre
fibre de bois en fin de vie alors
qu'aujourd'hui on sait recyclé 70 ou 88
% de l'INE minéral et 100 % du verre
vous perdez l'avantage qui a été celui
de la captation de carbone à origine par
ailleurs les biomatériaux il faut savoir
que bah pour qu'il y ait pas de
champignon dans le bois il faut mettre
des fongicides donc c'est pas forcément
aussi vert
ou amical pour l'environnement qu'on
qu'on qu'on voudrait le croire donc je
pense que ça occupe une petite part du
marché 3 4 5 % ça n'occupera pas 50 % du
marché et il faut pas d'ailleurs parce
que ça voudrait dire tuer la forêt
française enfin typiquement pour aller
chercher du bois et en plus de ça on
sait que la forêt française n'est pas
très compétitif en terme de coupe pour
précisément avoir plus de construction
bois et la forêt française qui par
ailleurs est mal en point contenu du
changement climatique est aussi un puit
carbone donc il faut il faut faire
attention sur les sujets biomatériaux
parce que fondamentalement il y a des
produits comme le verre qui sont des
produits minéraux enc une fois le verre
n'est pas un dérivé du pétrole
l'isolation laine de verre d'Isover
n'est pas un dérivé du pétrole c'est du
sable c'est du calcaire c'est du sucre
comm dans les Lian et on peut le
recycler 100 fois à l'infini avec
exactement les mêmes performance donc
voilà on a une offre fibre de bois parce
que certains acteurs le veulent c'est
c'est pas forcément les meilleures
performances thermiques c'est pas
forcément les meilleures performances en
terme d'analyse de cycle de vie certains
clients le veulent donc nous développons
cet offre mais il faut je crois modérer
l'enthousiasme parce que de toute façon
alors sur votre question sur les parpins
je n'ai pas en tête que nous travaillons
sur ces parpins là en revanche on
décarbone le béton parce que nous avons
investi 5 milliards d'euros chez
saint-gbin au cours des trois dernières
années sur ce qu'on appelle la chimie du
bâtiment qui permet avec des aides
juvant c'était une société qui s'appelle
criso ancienne propriété de la La Farge
il y a 20 ans qui permet avec des AD
duvent de décarboner le béton on peut
diser par TR ou qu la teneur en CO2 du
béton avec de la
substitution on fait des bétons d'argile
par exemple plutôt que de ciment et de
clinquer on peut mettre des cendres
volantes on peut mettre du laitier du ha
fourneau donc on fait plutôt ce genre
d'activité on fait aussi de la
construction en terre alors c'est plutôt
dans votre région madame la Présidente
en en région Provence ALP codazur pour
retrouver finalement des modes
traditionnels de construction en terre
mais avec un petit peu plus de science
modne pour s'assurer qu'on a toutes les
performances infinées donc voilà ma
réponse moi sur les les biomatériaux
c'est pas un champ d'expansion colossal
euh je donne un autre exemple sur tout
ce qui est bio parce que je crois que
c'était le patron de luftanza récemment
et je je veux pas tronquer sa citation
qui disait si je devais moi luftanza
consommer euh tout mon fiel en fuel SAF
je consommerai la moitié de
l'électricité
allemande donc vous voyez il y a il y a
des enjeux derrière les biomatériaux
derrière qui qui sont quand même
colossaux euh les isolation en chanre
très bien mais on va pas couvrir les
surfaces agricoles françaises avec du
chanre pour l'isolation on va d'abord la
couvrir pour l'agriculture et
l'alimentation donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut à la fois s'enthousiasmer sur ces
biomatériaux sur le biomimétisme qu'on
peut apporter dans la construction dans
les modes constructifs mais
fondamentalement il y a des produits qui
existent qui sont bons qui sont
recyclables à l'infini et moi le sujet
numéro 1 dans la décarbonation du
bâtiment c'est l'économie circulaire
nous avons été acteurs pour demander que
la Rep qui était initialement prévue en
au 1er 2022 elle est mise en œuvre au
1er mai 2023 qu'elle ne soit pas décalée
nous apportons 300 agences point P pour
collecter le recyclage et les déchets de
démolition des chantiers et ça c'est un
enjeu colossal pour baisser la teneur en
carbone dans le bâtiment c'est c'est ça
de très très loin le premier ordre de
grandeur dans le monde de la
construction c'est pas d'inventer des
produits bio qui vont dépeupler les
surfaces agricoles et qui auront une
performance en analyse de cycle de vie
voire en bien-être de la population on a
donné dans dans l'isol tion en laine de
chambre autre fois si vous mettez pas de
l'antimite vous tuez tous les costumes
et les habits de l'isolation à
l'intérieur on a donné la plume de
canard et puis quand il y a la grippe
aviaire l'isolation en plume de canard s
fond voyez donc il y a des isolants
traditionnels classiques qui sont très
performants en acoustique en thermique
en analyse de cycle de vie ce sont ceuxl
qui faut qu'il faut
promouvoir Vivian
Artigalas merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général merci
aussi pour votre exposé technique mais
passionnant j'ai appris plein de choses
voilà moi je saint-gobbin veut se
positionner en tant qu'acteur central de
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiment
et ce via plusieurs aspects moi je
voulais vous interroger sur deux de ces
aspects vous avez parlé d'accompagnement
spécifique des projets de rénovation
chez les plus démunis est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner quelques actions
concrètes de Saint- Goubin à la matière
ensuite sur la les questions des
rénovations globales et performantes ça
exige une coordination de différents
encore de métier et cette filière de
coordination n'existe pas en France vous
l'avez bien dit ça amène des monogestes
avec ma primerine renve alors changer
mettre une pompe à chaleur dans un
bâtiment qui n'est pas isolé je pense
que c'est une une erreur fondamentale il
faut d'abord isoler et puis ensuite on
voit quel système de chaumage est le
plus adapté et je vois ça fonctionne
beaucoup en monogeste actuellement
est-ce que ce sujet de la de vous vous
avez parlé vous vouliez former 10000
artisans par an au au aux enjeux
environnementaux est-ce que cette sujet
de la coordination de la rénovation
globale sera abordé et est-ce que vous
pensez que vous envisagez d'être moteur
dans la création de cette filière de de
coordination de de ces rénovations
globales et performante je vous remercie
ce sont autant de sujets qui ont été au
cœur de la commission d'enquête que j'ai
présidé dont le rapporteur était
Guillaume gantard et d'ailleurs nous
nous vous avions auditionné dans ce
cadre Monsieur le Directeur général
c'est à vous merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice pour votre question c'est un
sujet effectivement qui nous tient à
cœur et qui est au cœur de nos de nos
activités alors les actions concrètes de
saintobin c'est d'abord une présence sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur à la
fois la recherche et développement pour
être capable de mesurer de documenter
vers des produits de plus en plus
performants c'est naturellement la
fabrication en France de tous ces
matériaux nous avons plusieurs usines de
plaques de plat cognac Chambéry vos jour
plusieurs usines d'isolation sur le
territoire beaucoup d'usines de mortier
de fabrication de verre plat et cetera
c'est aussi comme je l' évoqué 2000
agences euh au plus près des artisans
sur les 450000 artisans référencés à la
CAPEB et et les entreprises de la FFB
quasiment toutes achèteent chez cbains
ça veut pas dire qu'elles achètent 100 %
de leur besoins chez cbain mais 85 à 90
% des artisans ont un compte chez cbain
et concrètement nous avons développé
depuis plusieurs années des logiciels
qui leur permettent caprenve solup plus
qui leur permettent de faire des devis à
la fois au plan financier très
rapidement avec les les prix exacts de
calpinage pour savoir exactement quel
quel est le volume d'isolation quels
sont les différents matériaux en terme
de quantité qu'il faut sur tel ou tel
chancher donc leur faire économiser du
temps pour que eux-même puisse faire
plus de chantiers leur permet d'avoir un
devis très professionnel en terme de
tenue vis-à-vis du du client final nous
avons lancé aussi des CFA pour former
les artisans c'est l'école du toit pour
les couvreurs c'est l'école des
bâtisseurs chez po c'est 19°gr une école
CDO 19°gr donc pour tout ce qui est
plombier climatiseur et et chauffagiste
donc nous faisons beaucoup de d'actions
de de formation à la fois sur des
nouvelles générations et à la fois sur
des artisans existants nous avons
effectivement grosso modo 10000 artisans
formé RGE ou qu'on aide à être formé RGE
un point sur le RG je pense que moi je
suis frappé
d'entendre les les représentants CAPEB
notamment dire écoutez le RGE vous ne
demandez pas à tous les transporteurs de
France de repasser le permis de
construire le permis de conduire pardon
tous les tous les 5 ou 10 ans demander à
un artisan d'aller passer plusieurs he
pour passer un examen on demande pas aux
infirmiers aux infirmières de repasser
leurs études bon sinon eux disent venez
auditer un chantier venez trois fois sur
un chantier à l'aveugle puis si trois
fois de suite il y a des ponts
thermiques un toit qui fuit vous me
disqualifiez je n'ai pas accès ou je ne
permets pas au chantier d'avoir accès à
la prime renve ou au soutien public mais
me demander ou demander aux artisans
donc je crois qu'il y a 62000 artisans
qui sont qualifiés RGE donc grosso modo
15 % de passer sur les bandes école
alors qu'ils font bien leur travail pour
99 % des cas parce que moi je leur fais
confiance comme je fais confiance aux
équipes de saint-gemin alors si c'est un
outil pour rendre plus contraint le
dispositif financier de la prime renove
bah c'est pas tout à fait l'objectif
recherché donc je pense que RGE il faut
l'assouplir et puis on peut auditer à
l'aveugle avant et après donc voilà une
remarque parce que je pense qu'il faut
dégouloter ce ce mécanisme encore une
fois qui n'existe pas dans d'autres
professions on va pas demander au euh
aux différents acteurs de repasser un
examen régulièrement donc pour autant on
essaie de les former pour leur faire
gagner du temps sur le test RGE nous
avons récemment lancé une filière
d'accompagnateurs Renov dans nos équipes
pour que précisément on soit capable de
prendre l'ensemble du dispositif alors
donc saint-gomin est très acteur nous
nous avons aussi lancé cette année je
prends un tout petit peu de recul le
premier observatoire au monde de la
construction durable qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire la construction durable donc
on a fait un baromètre interviewé 800
professionnels architecte artisan élu
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez quels sont
les freins quels sont les les facteurs
d'accélération on a fait un un panel de
discussion début juillet avec le
président de la fnaï avec Monsieur
Peltier avec des députés
Margoline mafer qui est récemment a
remis ce rapport enfin tout un tas
d'acteurs au cœur de ce sujet pour
savoir comment avancer plus vite et moi
j'étais à New York pendant la clam et
week la semaine du climat pour aux
États-Unis aussi avancer sur ces sujet
là on sera à Dubaï une troisème fois
pour avancer sur ces sujets donc on on
essaie de faire fédérit tous ces acteurs
parce qu'effectivement ce qu'il faut
avoir à l'esprit dans dans le bâtiment
si vous voulez c'est que la solution
technique existe faire une maison
passive dans les Pyrénées à Angers à
Grenoble ou sur l'ensemble de vos
territoires nous savons faire ce qui est
très différent de beaucoup d'autres
domaines industrielle dans
l'aéronautique ou autre la difficulté
pour nous l'innovation technologique
c'est de mettre en branle et de fédérer
toute une chaîne très fragmentée
d'acteur donc c'est pour ça qu'on essaie
de jouer ce rôle alors on va pas aller
jusqu'à dire c'est saint-gbin qui fait
le doctolib de de la rénovation
énergétique qui prend les rendez-vous
qui distribue les aides parce que je
pense qu'on serait critiqué de
promouvoir les solutions les produits de
saevin donc je pense que c'est quand
même aux acteurs publics de façon
probablement plus décentralisée qu'en
national parce que tout ça ce sont des
chantiers sur un territoire c'est un
maire c'est une communauté de communes
qui agissent ce sont les régions qui
font de la formation donc nous on est en
soutien de tout ça visà-vis des artisans
et et très très en lien avec les
fédérations professionnelles je pense
queensuite pour distribuer de l'argent
public pour coordonner toutes les aides
les ce de F d'un côté la prime renve
dans un autre ministère bah tout ça
c'est pas saint-gomin qui peut le
résoudre nous on est derrière avec tous
les acteurs professionnels industriels
et mais nous y sommes très attachés je
je pense qu'il y a des actes ensuite
symboliques importants je vous cite un
sujet sur lesquel nous sommes en
discussion on va demander prochainement
à toutes les entreprises de signer une
charte d'engagement pour la sobriété des
bâtiments tertières
privés TR pages de documents 12 pages
d'annexe le mot d'isolation ne figure
pas
il y a le mot rénovation le mot
d'isolation ne figure pas donc ça veut
dire qu'on est dans le concept l'énergie
en France existe elle est disponible à
l'infini à un coup marginal proche de
zéro parce que c'est du nucléaire et on
ne parle pas d'isolation donc nous nous
avons transmet plusieurs fois nos
remarques pour que le mot isolation sur
15 pages TR pages de documents 12 pages
d'ANC il figure ça n'est pas le cas et
nous a répondu que ça ne serait
probablement pas le cas donc moi je suis
dans une position difficile parce que
mon métier c'est d'isoler l'enveloppe du
bâtiment parce que nous savons partout
en Suède en Allemagne aux États-Unis que
l'isolation de l'enveloppe enfin on le
connaît depuis euh l'homme préhistorique
on se met dans une dans une caverne on
se met dans un iglou avant même d'avoir
mis une pompe à chaleur ou du chauffage
dans un iglou donc l'isolation de
l'enveloppe c'est fondamentalement le
premier geste j'ai dit ici dans cette
instance madame la Présidente
qu'effectivement une pompe à chaleur
dans une maison mal isolée c'est
conduire sa voiture les fenêtres
ouvertes avec l' climatisation à fond
mais si vous raisonnez sous un angle
purement CO2
vous vous dites effectivement si je
passe du fiou au gaz et du gaz à la
pompe à chaleur j'ai résolu mon problème
CO2 sauf que fondamentalement deux
sujets premièrement ça n'est pas
possible de ne pas apporter du confort à
nos citoyens qui soi en précarité
énergétique ou qui soit dans une
situation plus confortable confort
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire confort
thermique vous avez une meilleure
isolation donc vous n'êtes pas à 2 m de
votre fenêtre pour lire le journal où
vous ne grelottez pas à 13°grés chez
vous parce que pompe à chaleur ne
fonctionnera pas et deuxièmement un
confort en terme de facture énergétique
puis deuxième grand sujet si
effectivement on pense que il y a de
l'électricité verte décarboné nucléaair
en surabondance en France effectivement
il faut passer tout de suite sur la
pompe à chaleur si on pense que ça va
être difficile quand même d'avoir 14 pr
à plein régime avant 2030 ou après 2030
et ben je pense qu'il faut se préoccuper
de l'isolation des bâtiments donc le
dire dans un document officiel qui va
être envoyé à toutes les entreprises de
France Monsieur duplom Amel gaker merci
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur général le sujet
que je souhaite évoquer est celui de la
main d'œuvre et des compétences et plus
précisément la situation de pénurie que
nous rencontrons un sujet qui nous tient
en tant qu'élu he deso de France
particulièrement à cœur vous avez évoqué
notamment le cas de la gigafactory de
dkererque c'est 4 GIG oui il faut que je
me
rapproche si c'est bon ok donc oui je
disais je parlais donc de de la la
pénurie de main d'œuvre et de et de
compéten le secteur de l'industrie et de
la construction encore créé 15000
emplois en 2022 mais le manque de main-
d'œuvre perdure dans le secteur et ce
dans tous les corps de métiers à la
pénurie de main d'œuvre s'ajoute celle
des
compétences nous en avons parlé hein
nous avons évoqué la rénovation
thermique un chiffre aussi intéressant à
avoir en tête c'est les 220000 embauches
dans les métiers du bâtiment qui seront
nécessaires pour répondre aussi à cet
enjeu très très prochainement pour les
seules ouvriers qualifiés c'est 100000
postes dont nous aurons besoin en tout
cas également sur ce pointont-là euh
dans un rapport d'ailleurs de 202 22 que
nous avions cécrit avec mes collègue
Sophie prima et franc Montauger nous
avons évoqué cet enjeu essentiel et nous
alertions sur la situation de
l'apprentissage et de la formation
professionnelle depuis 2020 le
gouvernement a multiplié les annonces et
les mesures pour inverser la tendance
notamment l'objectif d'attendre
d'atteindre pardon 1 million de contrats
par an d'ici 2027 ou la prime de 6000
euros accordé aux employeurs qui
recrutent des apprentis et des jeunes en
contrat de professionnalisation alors ma
question euh est est jeallais dire
simple mais est-ce que ces annonces pour
vous sont à la hauteur des enjeux qui se
présentent à nous dans ce domaine à
l'approche des discussion dans le cadre
du prochain projet loi de finances pour
2024 quelles sont vos préconisations
quel que pourrait pourriez-vous pardon
nous soumettre euh pour pour pouvoir
répondre en tout cas ces grands enjeux
qui qui se présent à nous et enfin
quelle mesure adopter selon vous pour
une meilleure adéquation entre l'offre
et et la demande je
vous merci c'est effectivement un sujet
très important d'avoir l'ensemble des
des
compétences
alors je je je pense que ce qui est
fondamental c'est d'avoir de la
stabilité et de la visibilité moi quand
je parle aux fédérations
professionnelles je constate et c'est
très positif et moi je le valorise que
le gouvernement depuis plusieurs années
a fait des efforts la Prim renve est
passée de 1 milliard à 4 milliards donc
c'est une évolution forte moi je
plaidais pour un plan Marshal avec 10
milliards par an pour notamment prendre
ce qu'on avait dépensé sur le bouclier
tarifaire et le diriger sur les
bâtiments F ETG j' pas complètement
répondu d'ailleurs à la la principale
question sur les les personnes en
précarité de de flécher toutes les aides
sur les FG pour le le faire très vite
donc je pense que si petit à petit on
arrive à donner de la visibilité et la
stabilité dans le temps moi les
président président de considération me
disent on sera capable d' boncher on
craint toujours que ce soit une année et
puis que l'année d'après ça disparaisse
dans le rapport parlementaire précédent
je crois qu'on rapport propose de passer
à 15 milliards d'ici 2030 donc voilà
visibilité stabilité sur les mécanismes
un plan par exemple comme la rénovation
des écoles qu'a annoncé le ministre
Béchu c'est quelque chose de favorable
de positif parce que petit à petit on
peut s'engager et et donc les artisans
peuvent embaucher donc je pense que
visibilité stabilité sur les positif
pour dire il y a un vrai plan 2030 dans
le bâtiment dans dans les propositions
de France 2030 il y avait rien sur le
bâtiment moi j'en ai parlé plusieurs
fois avec Bruno Bonnel il y avait rien
sur le bâtiment dans tous les sujets
France 2030 donc si on inscrit en terme
d'investissement des sujets d'ici France
2030 qui vont stabiliser les mécanismes
vous voyez que tout le débat aujourd'hui
c'est pas à moi de le qualifier sur le
DPE est-ce qu'il faut le décaler est-ce
qu'il faut le garder est-ce qu'il faut
changer est-ce que ce sera 2025 c'est
2028 bah ça crée beaucoup d'instabilité
parce que dans un environnement du monde
du bâtiment qui est très difficile les
chiffres de 5 bains sont publics mais
nos chiffres c'est des baisse de 6 à 7 %
de volume sur le premier semestre donc
de fait le la rénovation euh madame la
Présidente me poser la question ne
compense pas l'activité neuf qui baisse
très fortement donc quand de surcroix il
y a des débats sur on décale les
contraintes on remet en en cause
éventuellement le DPE vous voyez que ça
crée de la fébrilité voilà je pense que
le le degré 1 c'est de la visibilité de
la stabilité il y a une parole de l'État
sur en 2025 les passeoirs thermiques en
2028 sur le logement social et c'est ça
qu' faut arriver à à à donner comme
comme visibilité parce que les
industriels comme le monde du bâtiment
s'engagent sur des embauches et s'engag
sur plusieurs années donc je pense que
c'est vraiment ça après toutes les
filières d'apprentissage c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose qui a très très
bien évolué en France sur les dernières
années n nous avons également grosso
modo 2000 2200 alternants chez sbin donc
en France donc c'est quelque chose qui
qui est très favorable sur lequel on
peut on peut continuer nous avons fait
du mentoring de jeunes pour essayer de
passer de génération en génération dans
les dans les artisans de de PO P donc
tous ces sujetsl sont à bien connectés
il faut bien les connecter aussi avec
l'Éducation
nationale pour que le monde de
l'entreprise le monde des artisans
l'éducation nationale soit soit soit
bien en phase il faut revaloriser dans
nos esprits les emplois du bâtiment qui
sont des emplois modernes on mesure du
kilwh par mètre carré on mesure du CO2
on mesure une performance acoustique
d'une salle de classe nous avons fait
des corrélations entre l'absentéisme des
professeurs un métier exigeant et
l'acoustique d'une salle de classe parce
que si l'environnement est désagréable
vous faites de l'hypertension et vous
êtes malheureusement absent en partie
donc il y a beaucoup de documentation et
et et donc de revalorisation de ces
métiers de du bâtiment ça n'est pas
l'image qu'on peut
avoir y a plusieurs décennies donc voilà
c'est un ensemble de moi je n'ai pas de
solution miracle mais la première c'est
vraiment visibilité stabilité tout ce
qui est fait en apprentissage en centre
de formation c'est c'est très important
on on a participé à
plusieurs plusieurs partenariats aussi
avec avec avec des lycées professionnels
ont fait tout un tas de de choses
après je prends un exemple qui a touché
sbin quand on a avec le mécanisme de C
de UF considérrait qu'isolation des
combles n'était plus nécessaire parce
qu'on met de la pompe à chaleur bah nous
nous avions investi 40 millions d'euros
dans une une usine à anger en 2017-28
elle est arrêtée donc aujourd'hui on a
licencié les collaborateurs arrêter un
four d'isolation parce que on considère
que l'isolation des comble isolation
tout court n'est plus une priorité donc
voyez si on avait eu 10 ans de stabilité
bah nous on y croyait parce que on le
fait partout ailleurs l'isolation des
combl et vous avez peut-être reçu moi
j'ai reçu de la part d'engj la
déperdition de l'énergie dans un
bâtiment c'est 30 % le toit 20 % la
façade 10 ou 15 % donc commencer par le
toit à l'isolation des combles qui ne
nécessite pas d'envoyer toute la famille
à l'hôtel pendant 6 mois c'est assez
facile à faire certes il y avait des
abus bon il faut pas annuler un
dispositif parce que il y a 2 3 ou 5 %
d'abusah typiquement nous pensions avoir
de la visibilité sur 10 ou 20 ans 2 ans
plus tard ça a été arrêté donc
aujourd'hui bah on installe des pompes à
chaleurve des ouvriers moldaves et les
pompes à chaleur même si on essaie de
créer une filière elles viennent de
Chine donc c'est sur les sujets de
compétences sur les sujets d'engagement
des filières sur les sujets d'embauche
sur les sujets de d'apprentissage c'est
fondamentalement de la visibilité de la
stabilité et de la clarté dans le
disposi voilà moi je constate
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
ministres qui ont une opinion sur le DPE
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le
nouveau ministre du Logement qui est
quelqu'un qui a passé 30 ans de sa vie
sur le monde du logement mais s'il y a
un expert du DPE c'est le Ministre du
Logement donc essayons de parler d'une
voix sur ces sujets
là on partage combien Monsieur le
Directeur Général Anne Catherine Loisier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général alors vous nous avez
beaucoup parler efficacité énergétique
donc moi je voulais revenir sur la R220
mais j'ai j'ai compris avec la question
de mon collègue que la place du matériau
bois et de l'énergie bois n'était pas
votre votre priorité que vous étiez
plutôt séduit par le carbone euh par le
le béton on pourra en reparler hein
parce que vous avez évoqué les les
millions d'hectares de forêts qui
dépérissent en France et ailleurs hein
d'ailleurs euh euh donc si je vous suis
la bonne idée c'est de les laisser
dépérir et de libérer le carbone c'est
vrai qu'il y aura une autre option qui
serait plutôt d'utiliser le bois et de
faire en sorte qu'il soit séquestrés
dans des bâtiment et notamment dans
l'isolation donc je vais revenir sur
deux questions c'est euh l'impact de la
REP bâtiment dans dans vos activités en
terme économique et aussi en terme
logistique et puis sur le volet de la
concurrence énergétique avec les
États-Unis notamment je voulais savoir
dans quelle mesure selon vous les
perspectives peut-être de taxe carbone
au aux frontières pourrait pourrait
pourrait tenter de de de limiter en fait
ces ces impacts négatifs
merci je je voulais pas me méprendre
nous faisons beaucoup d'activités sur le
bio je voulais on fait pas de béton nous
on a en revanche des petites des petites
innovations qui permettent d'aider les
cimentiers et les bétonniers à
substituer dans leur béton par exemple
on vient d'acheter une petite société
qui fait des fibres et qui vont
permettre d'enlever l'acier dans le
béton pour mettre les fibres bac carbone
à la place donc on est sur la
décarbonation je disais juste que la
construction bois en France moi j'y
crois on en fait à tout un tas
d'endroits la difficulté de la France
c'est que la forêt française n'est pas
compétitive parce qu'elle n'a pas été
remembrée donc le bois en France pas
votre analyse on par bah il y a il y a
pas de Syrie compétitive en France donc
le bois en France il vient de Pologne il
vient de Suède et autrefois il venait de
Sibérie alors on va pas
voilàasion de parler de la de la forêt
du bon écoutez je je m'arrête sur le sur
le bois on est partant pour continuer
nos activités de de fibre de bois
l'impact de la l'impact de la Rep euh
alors effectivement c'est c'est beaucoup
un sujet vous avez raison de souligner
c'est beaucoup un sujet logistique parce
qu'il faut fondamentalement trier au
moment de la démolition du chantier
parce que dès que vous avez mis tous les
matériaux dans une seule ben après la
valeur est est perdue donc on utilise
nous nos agences de distribution pour
amener sur des chantiers si ou 7 big bag
pour trier le PVC l'aluminium le verre
et cetera on a signé des partenariats
par exemple avec maie de Paris pour que
tous les chantiers de la maerie de Paris
on puisse recycler les fenêtres ou la
plaque de PL plâre donc il y a un
premier sujet très important logistique
c'est à la source du chantier sur les
déchets démolition et ensuite comment la
filière permet de réintégrer ça dans les
dans les unes puisque techniquement on
sait faire la plaque de plâre dans le
monde on est déjà à 20 % de Gys recyclés
la laine de verre minéral encore une
fois les est minéral c'est 70 %. et nous
avons d'ailleurs permis à un ancien
dirigeant de saint-gobin c'était le le
dirigeant de placo isovert de devenir le
dirigeant de valobat qui est un des
premiers éco-organismes qui a main une
soantaine de partenaires qui organisent
ces ces filières donc après bah le sujet
le plus difficile c'est objectivement
les fenêtres parce que les fenêtres et
les pare-brises recycler une fenêtre ça
veut dire enlever la menuiserie
l'huisserie les poignets donc on peut
pas juste recycler tout ça donc il faut
désosser de même pour un pare-brise il y
a tout un tas d'antennes d'éléments de
de feuilles de plastique entre les les
deux planches de verre donc il y a toute
une activité logistique et nous ce qu'on
essaie de faire dans ce CASL c'est à la
fois mettre à disposition donc des big
bags sur un chantier mettre à
disposition nos plateformes nos agences
physiquement sur le territoire pour que
il y en a 300 d'entre elles qui sont
labellisé valobat pour que les artisans
de la capB ou la FFB apporte leur
déchets là et qu'ensuite ça reparte dans
les usines donc on a fait beaucoup de de
d'activités le là-dessus donc c'est
essentiellement ça nos nos efforts
logistiques encore une fois il y a pas
de de difficultés technique on on a des
des unités de tri sur nos usines parce
que quand on nous renvoie du calcin de
verre si vous recyclez une bouteille de
badois rouge ou de Perrier vert dans du
vitrage ça va pas aller du tout si vous
avez le moindre oxyde de fer dans du
vitrage vous allez faire des bulles dans
votre four pendant 3 semaines donc ça va
être catastrophique donc il faut arriver
à trier trier trier et ce qui est
intéressant de ces sujets circulaires si
vous voulez c'est que il faut être
multi-industrie au sein de saint-gobin
ou avec des partenaires parce que par
exemple dans le verre la composante la
plus exigeante c'est pour le verre plat
puisqu'il faut une qualité optique après
le verre recyclé de moindre qualité on
peut le mettre dans la laine de verre
puisquon va reg regard on va pas
regarder l son journal à travers un
matelas de laine de verre après il peut
y avoir des déchets avec de la céramique
dans lequel on peut substituer du ciment
par ces matériaux là pour nos mortiers
par quand on fait de la la col carrelage
ou des endus de façade donc on peut
substituer et et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est en dégradant dans l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur les produits
recyclés que vous arriz à les valoriser
au mieux et donc il faut des boucles
locales multi-industrie pour le faire ce
qu'on on a fait également dans plusieurs
pays et on regarde ça en France c'est
quelque fois de prendre une
participation au capital de façon minor
ire dans un acteur de recyclage c'est
pas notre métier de faire du recyclage
on n'est pas volia on n'est pas suè mais
il peut y avoir des PME qui montent en
puissance sur ces sujets là et nous on
prend 5 10 30 % du capital pour les
sécuriser financièrement pour de
surcroix leur donner un un client captif
parce qu'on leur dit bah oui on
reprendra ce qui vous et leur donner une
sécurité financière donc on l'a fait en
Autriche on l'a fait au Brésil on est
partant pour le faire dès qu' a des
opportunité moi je pousse beaucoup
beaucoup les sujets si vous voulez tous
ces sujets là il y a il y a 6 7 ans
c'était vu un tout petit peu dans C
certains domaines ou certains pays comme
une contrainte reprendre des déchets bon
aujourd'hui c'est pris comme une
opportunité même stratégique de se dire
il faut économiser du sable même le
sable est une ressource rare aujourd'hui
en France et donc avoir accès à des
matières recyclées c'est stratégiquement
très important et objectivement dans le
monde du bâtiment c'est pas
antinomique si on pense à quelques
millénaires en arrière les pierres des
Égyptiens ont été un petit peu utilisé
par les Grecs et quand vous visitez
Sainte-Sophie il y a des temples du des
colonnes du temple d'Artémis donc le
réemploi et quand il y avait des
destructions on réutilisait les pierres
donc le réemploi dans le monde du
bâtiment c'est pas après on a aussi nous
des activités pour designer des produits
en modularité par exemple le village
olympique qu'on a fait en sa sy avec
Vincy on a inventé des cloisons
particulière de plaques de plat qui
permettront sans les casser sans les
démolir de recycler le village olympique
en bureau logement après donc ça c'est
mieux quand on le design à l'avance
plutôt que de de l'improviser après donc
il y a toute la modularité il y a des
questions qui sont pas FA facile le
réusage des matériaux si vous vouliez
changer le la physionomie la décoration
de votre hôtel et vous dites j'ai plein
de portes disponible pourquoi je les
donne pas au lycée d'à côté bah le lycée
d'à côté s'il les prend il a pas
l'assurance il a pas l'énorme antifeux
et donc ce serait très bien de pouvoir
le faire mais il y a tout un tas de
contraintes réglementaires qui
aujourd'hui ralentissent ces dispositifs
et c'est pas facile d'y répondre parce
qu'on peut pas dire on prend les portes
de l'hôtel on le met dans le lycée d'à
côté avec les mais mais c'est des
contraintes qui
existent Anne-Catherine aussi POS la
question sur la taxe carbone frontièrre
de l'Union européenne comme c'estement
une question qui va revenir et ensuite
malgré la qualité de vos réponsse si on
peut être un peu plus si vous pouvez
être un peu plus synthétique parce qu'on
narrivera peut-être pas à faire passer
l'ensemble de nos collègues alors la
taxe carbone oui nous on plaide pour ça
c'est un dispositif qui est quand même
très compliqué qui se met en place qu'à
un cas donc il faut toute façon il peut
pas être parfait du jour au lendemain je
pense qu'il faut essayer de le rendre
aussi complet que possible parce que ne
taxer que l'acier ça va rendre moins
compétitif les constructeurs automobiles
donc si on arrive bah taxer carbone une
voiture électrique chinoise qui arrive à
ce moment-là on a une vraie réponse donc
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à à faire
monter en puissance c'est une taxe
carbone aussi complète que possible pour
protéger un petit peu sur ces sujetsl
l'engagement de l'Europe qui est plutôt
en avance de phase sur le donc
oui le dispositif est compliqué mais il
faut pas l'annuler pour autant il faut
plutôt le parfaire et et essayer de le
rendre aussi complet que possible que
que de l'annuler merci Serge
merilou
Monsieur le Directeur Général ma
question portait sur l'utilisation du
bois donc je suis pas sûr que elle tombe
elle tombe à pique je je je je croyais
que dans l'évolution des matériaux de
construction don saintgobin est quand
même un spécialiste le bois pouvait être
une solution pertinente je le croyais
jusqu'à il y a quelques minutes je le
crois toujours d'ailleurs son cycle de
vie est quand même très positif et
puisque sa production est bac carbone et
qu'en fin de vie il peut encore être
utilisé pour la production d'énergie je
je pense que saint-gobin est très engagé
dans l'économie circulaire et je voulais
savoir donc quelle était quelle place la
filière bois occupa ou pouvait-elle
occuper en matière de décarbonation de
l'industrie alors comme je pense cette
question là n n'est pas forcément
appropriée je voulais aussi vous
interroger sur l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle chez chez
saint-gobin que vous que vous utilisez à
des fins de réduction de la consommation
énergétique
si si mes données sont sont bonnes et
pensez-vous prévoyez-vous d'autres
utilisations de l'intelligence
artificielle euh dans le domaine de déc
décarbonation de
l'industrie merci monsieur le sénateur
vous me permettez quand même justement
de corriger parce que je vrais pas vous
laisser avec cette impression moi je
suis très partisan du bois on construit
en bois aux États-Unis en Norvège en
Suède au Japon depuis toujours donc donc
on pousse le bois si si non non mais on
a tout on a même des catalogues pour la
construction bois parce qu'on adapte
aussi nos propres produits par exemple
la construction bois l'acoustique est
est un problème donc il faut des
matériaux d'isolation qui répondre à
l'acoustique euh parce que l'acoustique
dans le bois est plus facilement
transmise que dans d'autres matériaux
donc on on
estord vous avez raison le le village de
saint-gobin était dans la forêt de
saint-gobin qui existe toujours donc ne
vous méprenez pas nous avons tout un tas
d' de nos produits qui vont dans la
construction bois je je disais juste que
euh l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie sur la
construction bois aujourd'hui ne prend
pas en compte et c'est plutôt un
mécanisme intelligent pour favoriser le
bois elle a une analyse dynamique sur la
construction bois qui n'est pas
exactement la même analyse de cycle de
vie sur l'ensemble des matériaux ce qui
est une façon intelligente de promouvoir
de façon à accélérer la la construction
bois je je redis quand même parce que je
pense que ça a été étudié Moutte fois
dans cette enseigne dans le cénacle du
Sénat que la la forêt française
vous prenez parce que moi j'ai regardé
l'investissement dans la construction
bois en France vous prenez ce que coupe
l'ONF aujourd'hui en France l'ONF n'a à
sa disposition que 20 à 25 % du
territoire des forêts la forêt française
moi je suis très partisan et très
convaincu puce qu'on a la chance d'avoir
un climat tempéré donc on a toutes les
essences possibles et imaginables ce
qu'il faut juste réaliser et je l'ai
vécu depuis 30 ans sur des activités qui
étaient du papier de la patte à papier
c'est que les coupes de bois en France
par rapport à des coupes de bois en
Suède où c'est des très grand territoire
ou en Pologne sont beaucoup beaucoup
plus petites donc la compétitivité de la
coupe de bois si on remembrait un petit
peu les forêts françaises qui sont
détenu par tout un tas de
particuliers c'est c'est c'est tout à
fait possible de rendre la compétitivité
de la forêt française de l'améliorer
pour rendre la construction bois en
France moi je suis ce qui voulait mon
souci c'est un de faire monter la
construction bois de avec du bois
français voilà
aujourd'hui c'est aussi mais je pense
qu'il y a un sujet permettez-moi
d'insister de remobbrement de la forêt
française parce que la taille moyenne
d'une coupe de forêt en France est
beaucoup beaucoup plus petite que ce que
vous avez en Suède en Pologne et
ailleurs et donc il y a beaucoup de bois
notre grand concurrent vous voyez dans
dans l'isolation fibre de bois notre
grand concurrent qui est shtaiko achète
on l'a regardé parce que une socié qui
était en vente récemment achète 80 % de
son bois en
Pologne c'est factuel et s'il aachète en
Pologne c'est pas pour le faire venir en
France c'est parce que c'est plus
compétitif en Pologne donc moi je faire
grandir cette filière bois en France et
je pense que c'est possible on a une
chance unique d'un grand territoire et
en plus d'un climat tempéré donc
travaillons tous ensemble mais ne
nous ne sautons pas trop vite sur le la
compétitivité de la forêt française mais
je je m'arrête là parce que je suis pas
un spécialiste du domaine et et et donc
je vrais pas et alors nous on y croit à
la construction en bois on y croit à
plusieurs titres je vous ai indiqué des
catalogue de construction bois et
j'auraai le plaisir de vous les envoyer
et on a une grande enseigne de
distribution qui s'appelle
dispanau qui fait précisément des
boispanneau et de la vente de
boispanneaux partout en france sans
parler de l'offre boispanneau de Point P
qui est le premier acteur en France vous
voyez la con bois c'est notre métier et
on le déploie à toute vitesse partout il
y a des territoires qui sont plus
attentifs à la construction de bois que
d'autres mais on le déploie partout
alors l'intelligence artificielle oui on
l'utilise dans nos
procédés dans nos sujets logistiques
aussi pour optimiser justement
l'empreinte carbone avec des
optimisations logistiques aujourd'hui
dans le monde de la construction est-ce
queil y aura d'autres applications
l'intelligence artificiel je trouve que
c'est un petit peu trop tôt pour le dire
euh donc pour nous c'est plutôt ce qu'on
appelait autrefois du 4.0 enfin le
l'utilisation de boucles fermées avec
tous les capteurs que j'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure pour optimiser en temps réel
nos nos procédés de fabrication donc on
a beaucoup d'investissements là-dessus
on a à peu près 80 data scientists chez
saint-obin qui travaillent en recherche
sur ces
domainesl donc on va continuer avec tout
un tas d'application on a par exemple
chez saint-gobin je crois pas qu'il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui le fassent
moi j'ai tous les mois Les chiffres de
saint-gobin compte de rés résultat mais
aussi les émissions de CO2 donc on a
automatisé dans toutes nos usines la
remontée des informations sur ces sujets
CO2 alors c'est pas de l'intelligence
artificiel mais c'est quand même de
soutiller en permanence sur tous ces
sujets de décarbonation parce que on
améliore ce qu'on mesure
bien merci Daniel
salmand merci madame la Présidente bon
je ne reviendrai pas trop sur sur le
biosourcé même si on a des excellentes
études de Lig Rae qui montre que en
analyse cycle de vie le biosourc est
quand même extrêmement performant je
reviendrai simplement sur le recyclage
on sait bien que le sable commence à
manquer au niveau mondial on consomme
400 millions de tonnes en France quelle
est la proportion combien consommez-vous
de sable et est-ce que vous n'avez pas
de souci d'approvisionnement je sais que
vous êtes très investi vous l'avez dit
plusieurs fois sur le recyclage quelle
est la part aujourd'hui du du vert plat
qui est recyclé est-ce qu'est-ce qu'il
faut améliorer dans la filière pour
vraiment bien collecté et même même
question sur sur le plâtre dernière
chose euh
faire durer quelque chose également
d'important quelle est la durabilité
aujourd'hui des des verrs
des des v enfin oui des des veres que
vous
sortez est-ce que ça dure 10 ans 20 ans
parce que on sait que souvent et bien on
change en permanence et il faut faire le
bilan carbone de de tout cela et est-ce
qu'il y a encore des marges de
progression sur les performances
thermiques de ces vitrages ah dernière
question c'est ma petite dernière euh on
ambitionne de refaire du photovoltaïque
de la production de panneaux
photovoltaïqu en Europe je suppose que
vous êtes complètement partie prenante
de ces potentiels JK Factory
merci le recyclage de alors le sable en
kilotonne en France spécifiquement je
vous répondrai après parce que j'ai pas
le chiffre de la quantité de tonnes de
sable qu'on utilise en en France mais ce
qu'on a fait depuis plusieurs années
dans ces activités c'est alors dans les
endroits où on les met en en terme de
produits par exemple nos nos mortiers il
y a du sable on utilise de plus en plus
des matériaux de substitution donc c'est
les déchets de démolition on peut
concasser le le béton on peut prendre du
laitier on peut prendre des cendres
volantes ce qu'il faut c'est avoir accès
à toutes ces sources garder la
performance technique du produit final
parce que quand on fait de la
substitution bah il faut s'assurer que
la source fiable reste dans les mêmes
paramètres donc on avance beaucoup sur
ces sujetsl et effectivement le le sable
est une composante importante mais je
n'ai pas exactement en tête le chiffre
de kil de tonnes de sable qu'on consomme
en en en en France euh la part de vert
plat recyclé on est grosso modo à à 10 %
aujourd'hui ce qui est peu et c'est pas
lié à la capacité technique c'est lié au
fait que bah recycler une fenêtre
l'artisan pour l'instant il préfère la
mettre dans une benne et votre vitrage
si vous avez un un pépin sur un vitrage
automobile jusqu'à présent ça partait à
peu près dans la ben parce que
effectivement il faut le dshosser il
faut le démonter avec la Rep ça monte en
puissance parce que encore une fois
techniquement c'est c'est possible de le
faire le plâtre on est à à 20 % il y a
des endroits au Royaume-Uni on est à à
peu près à 30 % de matière recyclé dans
le verre plat donc tout ça est
techniquement possible tous ces enjeux
c'est plus des enjeux de réglementation
parce que ça donne un cadre pour tout le
monde c'est des enjeux de filière à à
constituer et et de ce point de vue-là
les les mairies peuvent quand on signe
un partenariat avec la Mairie de Paris
bah c'est très puissant pour nous parce
que effectivement on est un acteur avec
80 agences de négo partout en
île-de-fance donc on peut récupérer ces
matériaux mais si le déposeur à
l'origine ne prend pas d'engagement nous
on va pas courir sur tous les chantiers
de France et de Navar pour les récupérer
donc la réglementation est importante la
solution technique existe et nous on
s'équipe avec des investissements pour
mettre des triis sur des usines pour
parce que par exemple recycler la plaque
de plat bah vous pouvez récupérer de la
miante des années 60 70 évidemment on
veut pas ça ni pour les artisans ni pour
nos employés dans les usines donc il y a
tout un tas de sujet derrière mais on
avance bien et et ça monte en puissance
le et et c'est une offre commerciale
maintenant puisque comme je l'indiquais
notre verre auré bas carbone qui fait 40
% de carbone en moins qui a été installé
par exemple sur le carré des Invalides
le la rénovation la réhabilitation du
l'ancien siège de la région î-de-fance
Nexity a mis que du verre auaé bac
cararbone 70 % de vert recyclé on a
lancer une plaque de plâtre en France
infini 13 c'est 5% 50 % de plâtre
recyclé donc tout ça est à la fois une
réalité industrielle et monte en en
puissance en offre commerciale mais
l'essentiel du sujet c'était la question
précédente c'est le la boucle la boucle
istique alors la durabilité de verre bah
vous avez toujours les miroirs de la
galerie des glaces à Versailles donc ça
fait 350 ans le verre sauf à le casser ù
il existe il est très durable après vous
pouvez avoir des changements de norme en
Allemagne en Suède on est sur du triple
vitrage depuis plus de 10 ans en France
il y a beaucoup de bâtiments publics ou
privés qui sont encore au simple vitrage
donc mais ensuite le verre en lui-même
un il est recyclable à l'infini et
deux il dure autant que vous ENF quand
je parle ver je parlais vraiment des
vitrages et du gaz qui est mis entre les
deux vitrages et qui fait que parfois la
durée de la longévité est plus faible
oui mais alors c'est ces sujetsl
évoluent techniquement et on a au moins
une décennie de très très bonnes
performance après dans la l'évolution du
vitrage on est passé par exemple dans la
re220 qui était une très bonne sur le
confort d'été donc il y a à la fois il a
tout un tas de de catégories de vitrage
pour garder la luminosité pour avoir du
verre base émissif pour avoir du verre
qure saisons à la fois qui préserve la
chaleur en hiver et qui la réfléchi en
en été donc il y a tout un tas
d'innovations qui existent dans le
vitrage le sujet encore une fois c'est
pas d'aller équiper toutes les maisons
ou les bâtiments public de France sur le
nec plus ultra du ver 5 le nec plus
ultra du ver 5b c'est un ver
électrochrome qui change opaque ou
transparent avec un courant électrique à
l'intérieur qui coûte encore un peu cher
parce que il y a pas encore assez
d'effet d'échelle on a équipé en partie
le siège de Vinc de saint-gobin de
nestley de tout Google en Inde avec ce
vert électrochrome là bah il vous permet
de d'économiser 30 à 40 % d'énergie
parce que vous n'avez pas besoin d'air
conditionné si vous avez la la lumière
Zénit B ça c'est le ver électrochrome
mais le sujet c'est plus par exemple bah
de passer ne serait-ce qu' au double
vitrage en France encore une fois ça
fait 10 ans qu'on est au triple vitrage
en Allemagne donc tous les bâtiments
publics doivent passer au double vitrage
après il peut yoir du double vitrage bas
mississif
mais le sujet c'est vraiment l'effet
d'échelle c'est l'effet d'échelle dans
la l'économie circulaire c'est l'effet
d'échelle dans l'application de
solutions techniques qui existe
aujourd'hui elles existent aujourd'hui
Fabien
gu pr au
dépourvu merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur général sagobin
c'est
une très belle
entreprise une longue histoire 350
ans des savoirfaire fait par des
milliers des centaines de milliers
d'ouvriers d'ailleurs hier il av un très
beau documentaire sur France tél nous
les ouvriers
on a parlé dignité de la classe ouvrière
intelligence ouvrière amitié fraternité
humaine je vous je vous je vous invite
chacune et chacun à le regarder parce
que c'est si rare qu'on donne la parole
à ces hommes et ses femmes qui
construisent encore notre pays et
justement moi j'ai la première question
Monsieur le Directeur Général vous avez
30000 salariés ici en France en 75000
dans le monde ça incombe beaucoup de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale nous avez parlé
beaucoup d'environnement moi je crois
que la question du sens au travail pour
la classe ouvrière est une vraie
question donc elle peut être amenée mais
il y a aussi une question c'est que on
est dans un moment d'inflation
extrêmement forte vos métiers et
notamment les ouvriers ce sont des
métiers extrêmement difficiles comment
vous vous envisagez la chose et
notamment est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour augmenter les salaires dans le pays
bah oui mais il faut qu'on ait une
discussion quand même avec le patronat
parce que à un moment donné on peut
construire mais si plus personne peut
acheter et en premier lieu vos salariés
la deuxième question c'est justement
aussi avec ponamousson vous le savez
1500 salariés qui ont connu au moins une
journée de chômage partiel pourtant il y
a un besoin croisant de canalisateur la
question de l'eau est qu'une question
essentielle on en perd beaucoup parce
que justement nos canalisations fu
est-ce que vous avez un débat justement
là avec l'État
pour avoir un grand plan de remplacement
de nos canalisateurs ce qui permettrait
justement de donner une perspective à
pon à Mousson et évidemment de garder
cette fondererie on en a tant besoin la
dernière chose et pour pas être trop
long moi j'ai un point de débat avec
vous j'ai entendu sur
l'énergie nos grandes entreprises
électrointensives elles sont en train de
régler le débat comme vous le faites et
c'est normal parce qu'une entreprise
elle a besoin de visibilité parce que
pour investir on a besoin de savoir
à quelle sauce on va être mangé
notamment sur la question énergétique
c'est pas la même chose si c'est 40 € 70
ou 150 et vous avez raison sauf que à
mon avis ça peut pas être comme vous le
faites mais je le comprends de manière
individuelle vous venez de conclure un
nouveau contrat avec Total énergie pour
15 ans qui vous donne une visibilité une
stabilité sauf que moi je pense qu'on a
on est à la croix on est au carrefour de
quelque chose sur la question
énergétique on a besoin d'un débat la
dérégulation du marché en nous a emmené
là où nous sommes et la libéralisation a
conduit à déréguler et à augmenter
fortement les prix est-ce que nous avons
pas besoin de débat entreprise élu état
sur est-ce qu'il faut recréer un grand
marché enfin un grand service public
dans dans ce pays notamment sur la
question de la stabilité parce que on a
reconstruit le pays à la sortie de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale parce que on a
nationalisé les 1300 entreprises
gazières éct et et électrique de ce pays
et justement avec la classe ouvrière sur
la question du charbon mais aussi des
entreprises et ça a donné de la
lisibilité moi je crois qu'on est à ce
moment de Carrefour et on ne règlera pas
le problème qu'avec des grandes
entreprises comme vous qui passent des
contrats à long terme avec Total énergie
ou un autre je cible pas
particulièrement totalénergie même si
j'aurais beaucoup de choses à dire à
Monsieur pouyan quand il viendra mais ça
peut pas être cela sinon tout le monde
les plus gros vont régler leurs
problèmes et on va laisser le reste
voilà et les dernièrees j'aurais plaisir
à vous revoir sur vos
jours beaucoup de
questions merci merci beaucoup pour
votre question alors oui nous la vie de
saintbin c'est d'une part des personnes
magasiners vendeurs dans notre activité
de négo de matériaux et ce sont des
ouvriers dans nos usines 85 % de
l'effectif de sa bain c'est ça donc on y
est très attaché et très attentif notre
raison d'être les inspire et le sens au
travail chez saint-gobins moi je suis
très attaché à ce que cette raison
d'être chacun puisse voir sa
contribution personnelle au succès
collectif et on affiche la raison d'être
dans nos usines pour que chacun puisse
se l'approprier parce que je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous que ce qui est
important aujourd'hui à la pour tout le
monde et encore plus pour les plus
jeunes génération c'est le sens au
travail et l'autonomie au travail on
fait chaque année une enquête de
satisfaction auprès de tous nos
collaborateurs ouvriers partout dans le
monde en Inde au Vietnam et en France on
a 82 84 % l'année dernière de to
participation l'enquête est en cours
cette année la réponse moi qui me fait
le plus plaisir parce que c'est la plus
impactante c'est est-ce que vous avez la
bonne autonomie dans votre travail 92 %
92 % de toutes les personnes 165000 qui
répondent dans le monde disent oui j'ai
la bonne autonomie dans mon travail donc
S et autonomie pour moi c'est important
parce que c'est un ouvrier qui sait
comment faire fonctionner sa machine
c'est un technicien qui sait comment
avoir la bonne maintenance sur la partie
inflation oui on a fait bouger les
salaires quasiment au niveau de
l'inflation moi je suis content parce
que les résultats de sa-gobin ont été
bons que la part variable par exemple
distribué en France elle a doublé en 4
ans le résultat net de sain a doublé en
4 ans la part variable en France a
doublé on aurait peut-être pu faire plus
ou mais en tout cas elle a doublé
exactement en ligne avec les résultats
donc le partage de la valeur on a 65 %
de nos collaborateurs qui sont 72 % en
France qui sont actionnaires du groupe
toute catégorie professionnelle confondu
donc c'est quelque chose de très
important sur Pont à Mousson le débat
avec l'État on l'a eu bien sûr qu'on
sait tous qu'il y a un besoin
gigantesque de plan haut mais le besoin
c'est 5 milliard par an c'est pas c'est
pas 400 millions donc on a un écart
colossal entre le besoin et
l'investissement donc les débats avec
Pont à Mousson et sur les sujets d'eau
oui on les a tous les jours on a un
débat depuis plusieurs années par exle
sur la clause de réciprocité vous savez
que en Europe depuis 2014 on a le choix
et la possibilité de fermer des marchés
publics en France ou en Italie ou en
Espagne à des entreprises qui viendrai
de de pays dans lesquels les marchés
publics ne sont pas ouverts la Turquie
l'Inde la Chine et cetera en France il y
a toujours pas de taxe juridique pour
que un responsable de commune puisse on
l'a demandé plusieurs fois à Bery j'ai
écrit plusieurs fois au ministre pour
que il y ait un texte clair sur la
réciprocité donc bah on a maintenant 70
80 communes qu'on a petit à petit
convaincu d'appliquer la clause de
réciprocité pour que effectivement on
utilise la production européenne et
française l'Agence française de
développement finance un nombre de
projets à l'international avec des
produits qui ne sont pas français on l'a
dit plusieurs fois donc les débats on
les a vous savez on les a parce que moi
je suis très attaché à l'avenir et au
futur de nos usines à long terme je
constate qu'il y a tout un tas d'acteurs
j'avais V eu des débats sur le canal de
Provence il y a plusieurs années qui
acheté de l'acier turque plus cher que
pontamousson Canal de Provence et la
région voilà PACA et c'est la Caisse des
Dépôts j'ai écrit j'ai dit bon donc donc
tous ces tous ces débats on les a après
c'est normal aussi que pte à Mousson
n'est pas tous les produits et toutes
les canalisations posées en en France à
court terme la situation est difficile à
court terme les collectivités qui sont
prises entre les dépenses
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
basculent plutôt sur des tuyaux
plastique que des tuyaux de fonte
malheureusement les tuyaux plastiques ne
sont pas recyclables comme le sont les
tuyaux de fonte donc on a aussi des
actions sur ces sujets là le le PPA que
vous évoquez avec total c'est aux
États-Unis parce que Total investit
beaucoup sur l'énergie solaire aux
États-Unis moi je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le fait que fondamentalement
pour un acteur industriel moi j'ai
besoin d'un d'un cadre compétitif de
l'État un cadre en terme de coût du
travail en terme de fiscalité un cadre
en terme d'infrastructure portuaire
aéroportuaire on parlait de la tout à
l'heure considère aussi que la France a
une chance infinie c'est d'avoir la plus
belle façade maritime d'Europe donc nos
ports doivent être compétitifs pour
qu'on ait du fraet de la logistique et
donc de l'industrie en France un cadre
d'éducation la décarbonation de
l'industrie ça vaudra dire des
ingénieurs donc de l'éducation dans les
mathématiques les sciences quand vous
voyez l'investissement en éducation dans
les sciences aux États-Unis ou en Inde
c'est des facteurs 10 par rapport à ce
qu'on fait en France en ce moment et
puis un cadre en terme d'infrastructure
énergétique je vois quasiment l'énergie
comme de l'infrastructure donc est-ce
que ce soit régulé pas dérégulé moi
c'est pas un débat qui m'appartient mais
pour moi le cadre dans lequel industriel
peut fonctionner c'est un cadre en terme
de fiscalité de coût du travail un cadre
en terme d'infrastructure portuaire
aoportuire un cadre en terme d'éducation
pour avoir accès à des ouvriers des
techniciens qualifiés compétents et un
cadre en terme d'infrastructure
d'énergie est-ce
que ça doit prendre telle ou telle forme
juridique moi je me risquerai pas à la
question j'ai mon opinion mais je ne
risquerai pas à la question Bernard buis
une autre fois Fabien merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur général
le groupe saintgobin a annoncé fin
septembre avoir conclu un accord
définitif en vue de l'acquisition datfil
NV acteur international de premier plan
dans les fibres de renfort pour béton
vous précisez que cette acquisition
datfil s'inscrit pleinement dans le plan
stratégique de saintgobin grow en impact
concrètement dans quelle mesure cette
stratégie permettra de réduire votre
empreinte carbone et celle de vos
clients avez-vous des chiffres à ce
sujet en quoi les fibres de renfort pour
béton sont-elles des matériaux utiles
pour la transition écologique merci
merci pour cette question j'ai un tout
petit peu répondu tout à l'heure en
citant cet exemple là c'est
l'investissement qu'on a fait depuis
plusieurs années dans la chimie de la
construction la chimie de la
construction donc le notamment les
aduvant vous avez besoin d'AD Juvent
dans le béton et dans le ciment il faut
garder à l'esprit que il faut enlever du
béton dans le bâtiment parce qu'on peut
et on sait le faire on va pas l'enlever
sur les ponts ou sur les infrastructures
aéroportuaires donc il y aura quand même
toujours beaucoup moins mais du béton ce
qu'il faut c'est passer à du béton bac
carbone et c'est possible on peut avoir
Vincy a fait des vooussoirs de tunnel
sur le Grand Paris Express avec 90 % de
CO2 en moins dans le béton du béton
ultra bas carbone donc pour y arriver et
avoir la même performance technique
mécanique résistance à la salinité et là
ce qu'on appelle la réologie du béton
c'està-dire la manœuvrabilité du béton
sur le chantier il faut des aduvents et
ces aduvents donc permettent de garder
la même propriété technique du béton
tout en substituant des matériaux des
cendres volantes du laitiers de ha
fourneau et enlever le clinquer qui est
fondamentalement qui fait 80 % de la
teneur CO2 du ciment et donc du béton
donc on peut diviser par TR ou qu la
teneur en CO2 du béton alors ces fibres
à quoi elles servent elles permettent
justement de garder la même performance
technique du béton tout en enlevant des
matières carbonées ou de l'acier parce
que vous avez beaucoup vous avez tous vu
des chantier on a l'impression qu'est-ce
qu'il faut 26 filins d'acier pour
renforcer le béton ou est-ce que 24 ça
suverit ou 12 bon donc on peut enlever
grâce à ces fibres qui sont bacarbon
c'est des fibres de polypropylène on
peut enlever l'acier dans le béton et
donc décarboné encore une fois on aura
j'aimerais avoir une autre réponse mais
non on aura besoin de béton pour des
ponts des tunnels et de et donc on peut
enlever du carbone dans le béton avec
ces innovations dans la chimie la
construction ou des fibres particulière
voilà c'est ça notre contribution Henri
Cabanel oui merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général de
la politique que vous engagez au sein de
votre entreprise pour la
décarbonation à ce sujet vous êtes
engagé en RSE Responsabilité Sociétale
des
Entreprises je n'ai pas vu d'ailleurs
sur le site quel est votre organisme
certificateur mais je voulais savoir que
pensez-vous de la RSE et de certaines
entreprises qui mettre en avance ce
label à travers une véritable
communication sans pour autant engager
les actions notamment dans les SEP
principes génériques de la de la RSE euh
l'ISO 26000 normes internationales
risquent d'évoluer et je voudis savoir
que pensez-vous de cette évolution et
comment la
voyez-vous nous ces sujets de RSE qui
sont très très très largement décrit
dans notre document d'enregistrement
universel c'est de loat notre auditeur
qui les audite et qui les certifie et
puis a après tout un tas d'agence
internationale le CDP Vigo et cetera qui
note à moins a vous êtes à moins sur
l'eau à sur l'environnement et cetera
donc il y a il y a beaucoup d'organismes
au-delà de nos auditeurs commiss recomte
qui surveill et qui note ces ses
engagements sur les sujets de la RSE si
vous voulez on on efface alors oui il y
a le l'ISO 26000 mais il y a tout ce qui
est
CSRD a on est face pour les entreprises
à une multitude de normes européennes
américaines qui bougent dans tous les
sens la taxonomie européenne je vous
donne un exemple la taxonomie opéen
passe d'un bon sentiment euh mais par
exle tout notre activité de négoce de
matériaux de formation des artisans et
on a évoqué plusieurs fois que c'était
la contrainte n'est pas prise en compte
donc saint-gobin dans la taxonomie
européenne vous avez 20 milliards
d'activités qui ne servent à rien alors
qu'on sait bien qu'on va pas installer
de la construction bois de la laine en
bois ou de la laine minérale par
l'opération du Saint-Esprit donc tous
ces sujetsl sont quelquefis un peu
perturbants pour les entreprises parce
qu'il faut gérer plusieurs normes
plusieurs contraintte selon que vous
êtes en Californie en Europe ou et
cetera la CSRD en Europe va se mettre en
œuvre en 2026 2025 donc à partir de
l'exercice 2024 on va s'y outiller ce
qu'il faut c'est à rendre les les
mécanisme comparable intelligible
effectivement pour que toutes les
entreprises soient noté ou observé de la
même façon accessible aussi parce que si
vous voulez la S la CSRD nouvelle
formule c'est 1000 lignes de reporting
supplémentaire 1000 lignes de reporting
sur 800 usines et 4000 points de négo
1000 lignes de reporting donc le but
c'est quand même d'avancer sur le fond
plutôt que de rajouter des lignes de
reporting non mais c'est la réalité à
laquelle on fait face donc et pour que
ce soit intelligible aussi pour nos
collaborateurs donc voilà il faut
avancer sur ces normes il faut si
possible qu'elles soi convergente elles
sont auditées ça je vous garantis que
c'est extrêmement solide et et je peux
dire que en interne moi dès que je met
le petit doigt sur quelque chose d'un
tout petit peu maladroit en terme de
communication j'ai des équipes
saint-gobin super exigeantes qui me
rappellent à l'ordre parce que j'ai eu
une maladresse de langage ici ou là donc
non ces sujets sont sérieux mais si on
peut avoir des normes aussi visibles et
stables est comparable C CLA et que ça
s'applique à tout le monde les sociétés
côté comme les sociétés privées Yannick
Jadeau merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général
euh vous avez mentionné et à raison la
perspectiv notamment des marchés publics
la préférence géographique euh quand je
portais il y a quelques quelques
semaines au Parlement européen un
amendement euh sur un by European Act
euh il a été soutenu de manière très
transpartisan notamment par les
eurodéputés français mais il faut savoir
que Bery ne nous soutient pas malgré le
discours du gouvernement depuis des
années sur l'évolution de nos marchés
publics Bery ne soutient pas la
perspective d'une préférence des
entreprises européennes dans nos marchés
publics de la même façon alors vous
évoqueiez la certification
RGE je vous ai trouvé un peu si je
pourrais me permettre ce terme je l'
trouvé un peu facile sur
RGE pour travailler pas mal avec la
CAPEB et avec les FD du
bâtiment la RGE c'est pas repasser le
permis pour un un chauffeur je veux dire
quand un chauffeur il passe au 44 tonnes
il a des heures de formation quand un
chirurgien a une nouvelle machine il a
des heures de formation donc c'est au
fond de la formation professionnelle le
problème des artisans et de tous les
acteurs comme vous l'avez dit au fond
c'est la stabilité de nos politiques
publiques leur visibilité leur
ambition et finalement le grand débat
que vous évoquez de manière sous-jacente
dans la plupart de vos propos c'est on
se donne des règles et des objectifs en
matière de décarbonation en matière de
rénovation en matière sur tous les
sujets mais on se donne pas globalement
les moyens et on n pas la volonté
politique de de réussir ces objectifs
donc on finit toujours à la fin par
mégoter sur les moyens et on finit à la
fin par revenir sur ces objectifs et
c'est ça qui déstabilise vos activités
je sais que saint-gobin a toujours fait
partie au niveau européen de toutes les
coalitions pour avoir des objectifs
beaucoup plus ambitieux sur l'efficacité
énergétique mais si vous mettez pas un
service public de la rénovation
énergétique si vous mettez pas les
moyens vous l'avez dit dans le budget de
l'État je vais dire c'est mafous et
pisaniféri qui disent aussi faut passer
une autre ampleur et il faut de la
stabilité bah à un moment donné vous
vous dites comment on va rejuger le
passage de fag et donc les artisans vont
être de nouveau perturbés vos
entreprises vont être perturbés donc au
fond sur la j'ai été le rapporteur le
premier rapporteur au Parlement européen
sur la la l'ajustement carbone au
frontière et ben à la fin vous faites
des quotas gratuit P en 10 ans parce que
vous voulez pas aller au bout d'une
politique industrielle donc par exemple
sur les quotas gratuits en matière le
maintien des quotas gratuits dans le
système des cotas européens qui fait que
l'ajustement carbone aux frontières va
pas être efficace qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez euh
alors excusez-moi si j'ai si j'ai pris
quelques images un peu mal à droite et
des raccourcis je je vous rejoins dans
votre remarque mais c'est c'est c'est
pour essayer d'avancer quand même le
plus vite possible une bonne nouvelle
qu'on me signale je l'avais pas noté dit
hier soir c'est que la clause de
réciprocité que j'ai évoqué semble-t-il
a été voté en CMP hier soir j'espère
qu'elle ira jusqu'au bout euh la la
fameuse clause de réciprocité sur les
marchés publics qui existent de par
l'Union européenne depuis 2014 et qui
est appliqué en Espagne en Italie et
cetera donc si ça peut effectivement sur
les marché publics
favoriser des achats européens qui sont
fondamentalement plus exigeants et plus
rigoureux sur la RGE je m'en réjouis
parce que c'est pas faux d'avoir écrit
et clamé au effort c'est ces sujets
plusieurs fois
euh donc le la stabilité publique oui
alors les les cotas gratuits de toute
façon ils disparaissent hein donc nous
on a une visibilité sur la la
disparition des quotas gratuit donc
c'est pour ça que on des carbones à
toute vitesse aujourd'hui on a encore un
tout petit peu de quotas mais pas pour
10 ans donc on sait très bien quelle est
notre trajectoire et on sait très bien
qu'il faut s'assurer qu'on soit en phase
avec ça donc je je pense que ça c'est
bien de donner de la visibilité pour
dire voilà à horizon 2027 à horizon 2028
ça aura disparu donc toutes les
industries doivent s'y préparer donc moi
je je pense que si vous voulez sur sur
les sujets du bâtiment comme sur les
sujets industriel et je je comprends que
ça puisse être frustrant pour la la
puissance publique et pour les
régulateurs on est sur des masses
d'activité absolument considérables
quand on veut décarboner le bâtiment
quand on a une nouvelle norme R220 bah
il faut un an un an et demi 2 ans pour
toute la profession la comprenne il faut
un an et demi 2 ans pour un permis de
construire donc donc c'est seulement au
bout de 3 4 5 ans qu'on va en voir les
effets donc il faut malheureusement
accepter cette inertie sur le monde
industriel cette inertie sur le bâtiment
parce qu'on parle de millions de
logements bâtiments publics bâtiments
privé de centaines de milliers
d'artisans et c'est pas parce que le
système n'est pas parfait au premier
jour qu'il faut pour autant le changer
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir la tentation
ce que je comprends de dire l'isolation
des comptes ça marche pas il y a un
effet rebond on bascule sur autre chose
attendez isolons toutes les comes de
France ça va prendre 15 ans et on verra
l'effet parce qu'on sait que ça marche
et on peut le mesurer on peut le
documenter maison par maison et à
l'échelle d'un pays le CSTB a fait la
carte de tous les bâtiments FG de France
bon donc donc prenons voilà il faut
avoir cette vision que tout n'est pas
parfait au premier jour la Rep n'est pas
parfaite au 1er mai on recycle pas
aujourd'hui mais ça donne une contrainte
de la visibilité et tout le monde se les
manches voilà c'est ça dont as besoin
une filière de la construction pour
embaucher un industriel pour baisser ses
coups de de de production que ce soit
sur des matériaux biosourcés ou sur
d'autres donc les quotas gratuits ça va
disparaître c'est connu c'est visible et
donc on fait avec Franck menanville
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur Général en fait ma ma
question va dans le sens de de celle de
de Madame Loisier peut-être pour rentrer
plus dans le détail de de les conditions
qui seraient les les les bonnes et
opportunes pour au niveau de
l'application donc de de l'ajustement
carbone au niveau de de l'Europe et
notamment vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminires le grand delta de de de
compétitivité entre et de coût de
production lié au au j'allais dire à des
sources énergétique carboné par
rapport à nos contraintes européennes
avec fabiet et Valérie léard il y a
quelques années nous avions travaillé
sur une mission parlementaire sur la
l'cide des rugés on appelait déjà à
cette époque la nécessité d'une
finalement d'une réciprocité entre ce
qu'on impose aux industriels européens
et en particulier français et à nos
importations est-ce que le mécanisme qui
est mis en place par l'Union
européenne vous semble suffisamment
ambitieux et et et complet et quelles
conséquence aussi euh cela peut avoir
pour votre dans dans dans votre
stratégie de groupe alors sans me merci
monsieur le sénateur de votre question
sans me défausser cette question nous ne
sommes pas saint-gobin le meilleur
représentant de ça pourquoi parce que
nous on fabrique localement parce que
nos produits ne voyagent pas on a 90
usines en France parce que on va pas
fabriquer de l'isolation en Turquie pour
l'amener en France en coup de transport
ça ne passe pas donc c'est vrai que nous
on est beaucoup beaucoup moins concerné
que d'autres par ces sujets de taxe
carbone et d'ailleurs même l'Iran nous
ça n'a pas d'impact direct ça aura un
impact sur l'économie américaine donc
sur la construction aux États-Unis mais
on va pas changer des investissements de
saint-gobin pour fabriquer des produits
aux États-Unis ou au Canada et les
vendre en Allemagne donc je suis pas le
meilleur acteur pour vous répondre le
seul qui est impacté par ça c'est pant à
Mousson qui de fait exporte et il y a
des produits importé d'Inde et
d'ailleurs en en France ou en
Europe donc donc oui pontamousson est
concerné moi ma réponse un peu de
principe mais je ça vous satisfait pas
c'est de dire plus on est sur des
mécanismes larges qui incorporent tous
les composants mieux ce sera euh encore
une fois je le monde automobile le dit
mieux que moi mais c'est donc voilà je
suis désolé je suis pas le meilleur euh
Daniel gremiller
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
directeur général d'abord merci pour la
clairvoyance de vosre propos en tant que
chef d'entreprise et sur le champ du
possible euh quand on se place par
rapport à un environnement concurrentiel
euh qui est vraiment important de nous
rappeler euh il y a une étude dans le
casadre du futur énergétique horizon
2050 qui a
été mise à jour en septembre donc il a
il y a quelques semaines et qui fait
état d'une du champ du possible de 100
taw d'économie énergétique provenant de
la rénovation aujourd'hui on est à peu
près à 100000 rénovations global par an
l'objectif 2030 c'est de passer à 370000
et 2050 on passé à
700000 et je vous pose la même question
que vos propos parce que je trouve
qu'ils sont très cohérents il faut
accélérer mais pour accélérer il faut
aussi rentrer dans le champ du possible
un avez-vous la capacité d'augmenter vos
capacités de production pour arriver de
passer de 200000 à 300000 plus
rapidement et le champ du possible c'est
le coût aujourd'hui le coût aujourd'hui
de la rénovation énergétique c'est
enflammé c'est envolé et et il ne sera
pas accessible à beaucoup de familles
donc le le vrai sujet de la
compétitivité est essentiel
deè point sur la pompe à chaleur al je
veux pas vous taquiner mais RTE n'est
pas d'accord avec vous et considère que
la pompe à chaleur peut être source de
25 TWh d'économie d'énergie donc ce qui
m'intéresserait c'était en une phrase
c'est qu'est-ce qui différencie votre
analyse de celle de RTE sur la
diminution énergétique et dernière
remarque loi de finance la loi de
finance on y rentre et on nous présente
à nouveau une modification de ma prime
Renov qu'en
pensez-vous merci
Daniel alors votre question sur les
capacités industrielles oui on est prêt
malheureusement on a même dû fermer des
capacités qu'on avait investi pour aller
plus vite l'isolation des combles avec
de la laine à souffler qui est un
mécanisme très pratique c'est ce qu'on
fait partout aux États-Unis on est
leader de l'ané à souffler aux
États-Unis on avait une nouvelle
capacité on avait doublé on l'a arrêté
elle est prête elle peut redémarrer en 3
semaines on avait prévu de faire une
nouvelle usine d'isolation en France on
l'a pas faite parce que le terme
isolation disparaît donc les capacités
industrielles elles existent on a même
des Unis suisses hollandaises qui qui
sont prêtes si jamais on faisait fois 5
pour voilà donc donc ça c'est important
le coût de la rénovation aujourd'hui si
vous voulez oui il y a eu de l'inflation
à cause de l'inflation énergétique je
retourne à la case despart si on
consommait moins d'énergie l'énergie
qu'on consomme en France serait moins
cher il y a eu l'effet dramatique de la
guerre en Ukraine qui a fait exploser la
facture énergétique mais aujourd'hui si
effectivement on avait une surabondance
d'offre d'électricité décarboné
nucléaire bah l'électricité serait moins
cherre c'est la loi de l'offre et de la
demande donc aujourd'hui l'énergie est
chère donc ça a créé de l'inflation sur
les matériaux parce que comme je l'ai
évoqué on a des matériaux qui sont très
intenses en énergie mais le sujet
principal de la rénovation on n pas
parlé du neuf aujourd'hui c'est le
financement moi je livre à votre
réflexion le fait qu'aujourd'hui le
monde financier en France n'est pas
intéressé à la rénovation énergétique du
bâtiment quand vous êtes prêteur
immobilier vous vous intéressez à votre
âge votre profession votre état de santé
si vous avez le droit c'est tout vous ne
vous intéressez pas à savoir si vous
aidez le particulier à passer de G à c
de F à B si vous faites un crédit
bonifié voire une déduction fiscale par
exemple sur les taux d'intérêt du crédit
à 4 ou 5 % quand il était un autrefois
sur l'inovation énergétique on pourrait
très bien imaginer si on considère que
c'est une priorité nationale que le
complément de prêt qu'on pourrait
demander par la réglementation au
banquier vous êtes banquier prêteur
immobilier en France bah vous devez
avoir 10 15 30 % de votre portefeuille
de prêt qui doit s'adresser à la
rénovation énergétique qui doit aider le
particulier à gagner une classe de
classe puis si vous avez eu un prêteur
qui a remboursé il a acheté sa maison
400000 € il a remboursé 250000 vous
devez lui proposer par une lettre
monsieur vous avez acheté votre maison
vous avez rénové les combles et changé
les fenêtres il serait temps de mettre
une pompe à chaleur voilà un crédit
supplémentaire de 10 1500 € pour votre
pompe à chaleur ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui donc moi je ne pense pas
qu'on a arrive dans la transition
énergétique des 30 prochaines années
dans le bâtiment si le monde financier
en dehors de la Caisse des Dépôts qu'il
fait très bien sur le logement social en
dehors de quelques banques mutualistes
Crédit Mutuel Banque Postale Crédit
Agricole
Île-de-France les autres banquiers ne
s'intéressent pas aujourd'hui au
financement de la transition énergétique
tout ça dans un monde où les taux
d'intérêts sont extraordinairement
élevés donc je pense que le sujet numéro
1 du coût de la rénovation c'est d'abord
un accès au financement c'est pour ça
que moi dans le plan Marshal que
j'aiévoqué je disais les 5 50 milliards
de boucliers tarifaires tout le monde en
avait pas besoin certains avaient besoin
de plus on aurait pu prendre 10
milliards de ça et les mettre
complètement sur les bâtiments FG
prenons la prime renve et dédion là
c'est quand même l'objet justement de
l'évolution d'albot finance fléchons
complètement la prime renve sur les
bâtiments FG pourquoi parce que c'est
des ménages en précarité énergétique et
s'il restent à charge est trop important
ils ne pourront pas le faire
deuxièmement c'est des bâtiments qui
vont sortir du marché locatif en 2025 et
en 2028 si on ne change pas la
contrainte et on a déjà un manque criant
de logement et à forceue de logement
locatif en France et tris le CSTB nous
dit qu'en plus ce sont eux qui font 70 %
des émissions de CO2 donc le bon sens
paysan vudrait dire l'argent public on
le met pas à 100 % sur le bouquet
tarifaire parce que certains pourraient
ne pas en avoir besoin on le met sur de
l'investissement plutôt que de le mettre
par la fenêtre si vous voulez je reviens
d'Inde ou en Inde grâce au digital on
est capable de subventionner exactement
le couple à revenu modeste par une
subvention bah en France on n'est pas
capable de le faire donc on arrose tout
le monde le bouclier tarifaire bon donc
si on avait plus de finesse dans les les
mécanismes de soutien on aurait dérigé
le bouclier tarifaire sur les besoins
qui en avait vraiment besoin et
probablement plus que ce qu'ils ont reçu
et deuxièmement on aurait économisé une
partie de l'argent pour le mettre en
vrai investissement alors moi je me
réjouis que la primofre passe de 1 à 4
et peut-être un jour 10 plutôt on passe
le message moi je l'ai demandé il y a 2
ans si on avait déjà eu le message 4
milliards il y a 2 ans bah probablement
la profession elle se serait mis en
branle il y a 2 ans plutôt que de se
dire ah on y va maintenant et voir
encore des textes qui nous disent pas
chzur mais pas d'isolation donc voilà si
vous voulez c'est visibilité stabilité
et financement donc je pense que le
sujet du financement il ne faut pas
l'oublier parce que sinon on narrivera
pas à financer la rénovation énergétique
il y aura pas même de tuyauterie de
financement et aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible que des acteurs très très
importants du monde économique soit en
dehors du du sujet le sujet de la pompe
à chaleur ne vous méprenez pas sur moi
je suis un grand supporterur de la pompe
à chaleur et on en vend beaucoup on a
notre enseigne c'est d' qui en vend
beaucoup je dis juste pour l'efficacité
thermodynamique et là encore une fois il
y a toutes les études techniques il faut
bien isoler pour que la pompe à chaleur
fonctionne la pompe à chaleur ça
fonctionne thermodynamiquement sur
l'écart de température extérieure
intérieur s'il fait 9°g chez vous quand
il fait - 5 dehors la pompe à chaleur va
vous faire passer de 9 à 13 mais pas de
9 à 19 sauf si vous mettez quatre fois
plus de radiateur sur les murs c'est de
la thermodynamique parce que c'est le
principe même de la pompe à chaleur donc
la pompe à chaleur est un extraordinaire
vecteur de chauffage très efficace en
terme de rendement mais sur suppose au
préalable d'avoir isolé le bâtiment et à
ce momentl ça marche merveilleusement et
d'ailleurs dans la rénovation globale il
y a quatre gestes l'isolation des comble
de la
façade du sol si vous avez une cave mal
isolée avec votre sol et le changement
du système de chauffage donc c'est ça la
rénovation globale mais dans le bon sens
donc il faut pas tuer les monogestes en
commençant par l'isolation plutôt que la
pompe à chaleur sinon on va avoir des
des conflits des drames juridiqu et
aujourd'hui vous avez un effet d'è
là-dessus c'est très bien la pompe à
chaleur on en vend beaucoup on en
fabrique pas mais on en vend beaucoup
donc moi je me réjouis qu'il a une
filière française de la pampe à chaleur
mais faisons les choses dans le bon sens
c'est juste ça que je dis RTE on est
tout à fait en phase avec ça merci
Laurent
duplom merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général moi je
bois vos paroles alors vous avez parlé
de bon sens paysan ça tombe bien je suis
un paysan donc ça va bien avec ce que je
peux penser et puis vous avez tellement
eu de question de votre gauche
géographique que je pense qu'il est
normal que vous ayez un peu les retours
de votre droite géographique et et je
peux vous dire que nous on est très fier
de saint-gobin et très fier de ce que
vous faites et très fier de ce que vous
venez de dire parce qu'à un moment donné
croire toujours qu'on est dans des
histoires qui consistent à raconter tout
un tas de choses sans se préoccuper et
de la compétitivité et de notre capacité
de production c'est finalement accepter
de façon totalement naïve que tout part
ailleurs et que petit à petit nous ne
produisions plus rien en France alors
c'est vrai qu'on arriverait avec ça à
avoir une multitude de choses qui
seraient peut-être meilleure mais en
tous les cas au bout du bout c'est pas
la vision que je partage de l'évolution
de notre pays alors votre prédécesseur
ou du moins celui qui l'a créé il me
semble que c'était Colbert Colbert était
une personne qui voulait redonner du
sens à l'activité française ce sens il
l'a voulu à travers l'indépendance cette
indépendance il l'a voulu à travers une
chose très simple c'est les matières
premières issues de notre pays qui
puissent permettre de fabriquer
l'excellence mondiale ou
européenne c'est ce que vous avezit en
350 ans ma question est simple sur ma
sur mon département j'ai malheureusement
pas la chance d'avoir une usine Saint-
Gobin mais j'ai une carrière qui
correspond à votre à votre activité la
carrière Samain rocharigner qui est
historique puisque elle tire de la
silice qui doit vous permettre de faire
du verre si on veut garder cette
indépendance il faut qu'on garde notre
capacité de produire de la matière
première sur notre pays mais là encore
on est confronté à une multitude de gens
qui nous nous explique qu'il faut faire
du verre sans prélever du sable sans le
prélever de la silice il faudrait faire
du verre avec le principe de lourde et
du miracle mais je voulais je voulais je
voulais je voulais Monsieur le Directeur
Général que vous m'indiquiez quel est
votre stratégie pour conserver ces
carrières emblématiques qui font que la
France conservera cette capacité là si
elle conserve de tirer sa matières
premières dans notre pays parce que
sinon si nous ne la tirons plus là quel
est l'intérêt de rester en France après
tout ce que vous avez dit en terme de
compétitivité et de difficultés qu'on a
à faire cohabiter l'activité économique
avec toutes les autres activités qu'on
nous raconte parfois virtuelles dans
notre pays
merci merci monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison nous on est très très
attaché à l'indépendance de saint-gbin
pour le pays pour saint-gobin et pour
tout ce qu'on apporte à nos clients à
nos sous-traitants et à nos à nos
équipes donc ça commence effectivement
par les matières premières la chance
qu'on a c'est que petit à petit on s'est
organisé avec des boucles logistiques
très locales par exemple pour vous citer
un chiffre nous la période covid en
terme de chaîne d'approvisionnement on a
jamais arrêté une usine jamais arrêté un
chantier de par le monde pourquoi parce
qu'on a moins de 1% de notre sourcing
qui vient de Chine nos sourcing tout
confondus ils sont pour l'essentiel
nationaux ou régionaux à l'échelle
européenne et ça démarre effectivement
des matières premières donc l'économie
circulaire est une composante importante
parce que de fait on va moins consommer
de matières premières vierges et on a
pris des engagements là-dessus parce
qu'on va plus recycler donc c'est
stratégique d'accélérer sur l'économie
circulaire avec les bonnes
compétitivités en terme de logistique et
c'est stratégique également de raisonner
sur les carrières donc pour nous les
carrières si vous voulez c'est des
sujets qui sont à long terme pas plus
tard qu'hier on m'a proposé de faire un
investissement dans une carrière de
l'Arcana parce que dans 20 ans on va
manquer de GIPS vous voyez on raisonne à
très long terme et on a besoin parce que
le temps d'exploitation le temps de
permis est un temps long et on peut pas
attendre 2 ans avant de se dire Flut on
va déménager l'usine sur roulette donc
donc c'est très important et
effectivement ça démarre aux carrière et
à la facilité avec laquelle on peut les
exploiter les ouvrir les réorganiser les
rendre à à l'aspect végétal post
utilisation une fois qu'on a pris les
matières premières donc on a tout un une
activité carrière qui est qui est gérée
au plan international et national pour
s'assurer que on fait tout ce qu'il faut
à la fois pour l'environnement pour
l'activité de saint-gobin vis-à-vis des
des car
des carrières évidemment en France vous
avez raison de souligner Martine
Berté merci madame la Présidente alors
cout de l'énergie formation des artisans
vous y avez répondu je vous en remercie
ma question portait sur la même chose
que mon collègue Laurent duup PL
c'est-à-dire face justement au à la
difficulté de plus en plus prignante de
l'acceptation par les populations alors
en contradiction certes avec les besoins
de production locale approvisionnement
local pour la décarbonation mais
certains de vos sites de production vont
arriver à épuisement donc je pense que
vous orientez vos recherches dans de
nouveaux matériaux de base de nouvelles
matières premières mais aussi voilà
comment mettez-vous en œuvre une plus
grande utilisation des matériaux
recyclables est-ce que toutes les
filières sont suffisamment performantes
pour vous ou est-ce que ça pêche encore
chez certaines mercici beaucoup madame
la sénatrice alors nous nous avons
quatre piliers de recherche et
développement l'un des quatre c'est
précisément l'exploitation de l'économie
circulaire donc on a quatre domaines un
c'est la décarbonation de nos procédés
de avancer sur des systèmes de
construction légèr notamment la
construction bois et tout ce que ça veut
dire sur nos matériaux qure inventer des
nouveaux matériaux pour la batterie
électrique et puis le troisème c'est
l'économie circulaire et donc ça ça veut
dire substituer des matières par exemple
et autrefois on utiliser du carbonate de
calcium dans la composition du verre
pour nos fours aujourd'hui on passait
sur du silicate de calcium la
volastonite je n'étais pas un expert de
la volalonite il y a quelques années
mais nos chercheurs ont travaillé dessus
alors il y a des carrières de
volalstonil qui sont réparties
inégalement de par le monde il y en a
beaucoup en Inde donc par exemple on a
des fabrications de verre en Inde avec
80 % 90 % de volastonite donc il y a
beaucoup d'activités de recherche et
d'innovation sur la substitution de
matièrees carbonées par d'autres et
également sur les matériaux recyclés la
difficulté toujours dans les matières
recyclé c'est un d'avoir la
compétitivité de la boucle de recyclage
et deux de contrôler la formulation
parce que nous on a quand même des
formulations matière qui sont
extraordinairement précises en fait
c'est pas à 10 % près c'estion de silice
de pureté de C de ça donc on peut pas se
permettre de dire tiens on va prendre
des déchets de béton d'un pont puis des
déchets de béton d'autres choses du
verre comme si donc il faut être capable
c'est à nous de le faire d'avoir des
mécanismes de tri d'avoir des mécanismes
de sélection d'avoir des stoiométries
particulières pour que à la fin on soit
capable d'être très versatile dans les
matériaux recyclés qu'on qu'on récupère
mais pour autant qu'on respecte les
formulations qui nous permettent de
faire des bons produits donc donc il y a
beaucoup de recherches là-dessus et je
peux dire que les les équipes de
recherche de 520 sont très motivés en
fait le on a vraiment l'impression sur
ces sujets de décarbonation qu'on est à
la tête de gigantesque start-up parce
que tout bouge il faut faire du verre
avec de l'électricité plutôt avec du gaz
il faut récupérer des matières premières
il faut substituer du ciment par des
cendres volantes il faut aller chercher
du laitier et du laitier de haut
fourneau selon qui vient de pont àousson
d'Arcelor c'est pas le même donc comment
ça change le paramètre technique à la
fin il faut après passer par les
qualifications CSTB ça prend un an et
demi 2 ans donc donc voilà mais il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de foisonnement très
intéressant scientifiquement et
industriellement sur les sujets de
décarbonation procédés matériaux et
matériaux recyclés donc je peux dire que
les équipes de 520 sont très très très
mobilisé parce que c'est même des défis
scientifiques et techniques tout à fait
passionnants remémy Cardon merci Madame
Mame la présidente monsieur Bazin
j'aurais une question en particulier sur
sur tout ce que vous êtes dit en ce que
vous venez de dire à mes à mes collègues
si on prend et dans votre champ lexica
vous avez exprimé beaucoup de mots
autour de clarté visibilité
assouplissement et dans vos propos sur
France Info vous avez exprimé le fait
qu'il fallait passer sur une logique
d'investissement donc si on se projette
et qu'on lance une loi pluriannuelle sur
la rénovation thermique un plan marshal
de pas de 50 milliards sur les 5 ou 7
ans prochains euh selon vous parce queil
faudrait que ça soit accompagné
justement et qu'on a inscrit dans la loi
des priorités d'action pour permettre
aux acteurs de la rénovation un cap et
des perspectives stables pour conforter
justement la performance des travaux et
aller vers une massification des
interventions donc selon vous quelles
sont les priorités d'action que l'on
peut inscrire et proposer au
gouvernement demain et peut-être en
citer tout simplement trois euh selon
votre votre votre filière
voilà alors moi j'ai bacarbone à moin 20
% de cûpt dans 10 ans on va faussefort
pour essayer d'y arriver le plus vite
possible le les les les quelques points
moi qui me paraissent très importants
c'est
euh premièrement de ne pas changer le
dispositif que beaucoup de pays nous
envit beaucoup de pays nous envit moi
quand je parle à des investisseurs quand
je voyage beaucoup de pays nous envie le
mécanisme du DPE et le mécanisme qui
consiste à dire il y a un minimum
d'efficacité énergétique à viser et on
traite les plus malades et petit à petit
on les améliore donc ce mécanisme qui a
existé depuis plusieurs années on peut
pas dire qu'on le découvre d'avantiè
donc les acteurs de la profession quel
qu'il soit ne peuvent pas se dire je n'y
arriverai pas en 2025 et d'ailleurs en
2025 si on regarde seulement les
propriétaires locataires sur les FG
c'est pas non plus des montants
astronomiqu de rénovation à réaliser si
vous êtes propriétaire dans votre maison
F ou G vous n'avez pas l'impératif de
quitter votre maison au 1er janvier 2025
c'est pas du tout ce que la loi dit donc
je pense que la stabilité du
DPE et du traitement des FG et petit à
petit de remonter le curseur c'est
fondamental et encore une fois beaucoup
de pays nous l'envie quand j'ai décrit
ça aux États-Unis à New York qui est
quand même assez avancé sur le sujet ils
veulent essayer de le mettre en place
les Allemands essayent de le faire les
Anglais ont un petit peu l'équivalent
donc ça c'est la la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est de surtout engager
les bâtiments publics engager les
bâtiments publics 60 % c'est 10
milliards d'euros de dépenses de
chauffage les bâtiments publics donc
quand on cherche des sous si on divise
par 5 parce qu'on sait le faire bah vous
économisez 8 milliards bon 8 milliards
c'est le montant dans le budget 2024 de
France
2030 donc voyz qu'on peut les économiser
juste avec la facture de chauffage on va
pas rénover tous les bâtiments publics
de France instantanément mais il faut de
la visibilité et des engagements en
terme de montant sur les bâtiments
publics et privés moi j'ai été voir je
me réjouis qu'il y ait un plan sur les
écoles 70 % c'est les établissements de
santé et d'éducation qui sont des
professions par ailleurs
extraordinairement
exigeantes professeur ou ou soignant
donc siblons les efforts sur les
bâtiments publics et typiquement il y
avait trois scénarios soit vous faites
rien et tout se fait entre 2040 et 2050
soit vous le faites au fil de l'eau soit
vous le faites avec un paquet
d'investissement tout de suite bon sur
les écoles moi je préconisais 8
milliards par an on a 2 milliards sur 5
ans c'est bien c'est mieux que rien mais
2 milliards par an 2 milliards sur 5 ans
sur 40000 30000 école ça fait 10000 €
par école et par an donc c'est mieux que
rien et toutes les écoles n'ont pas le
même besoin mais voilà donc il faut
changer d'échelle et viser les bâtiments
privés et publics si dans 3 ans on finit
à 10 milliards de la prime Reno bah
autant y aller tout de suite parce que
il y aura un signal tout de suite et
qu'on ait une loi pluriannuelle de
programmation je pense que ce qui est
très bien c'est que sur la planification
écologique on est rentré dans une
logique de planification parce
qu'effectivement il y a besoin d'une
visibilité à à 10 ans voire à 30 ans
donc soyons dans cette logique de
planification et avec bâtiments publics
et bâtiments privés et des efforts en
masse plus plus substantiel autre sujet
c'est de simplifier les dispositifs je
pense qu'il y a intérêt pour aller plus
vite peut-être à territorialiser les
choses à s'assurer que je suis en région
je suis en mairie j'achète un bien
immobilier je connais le maire je
connais l'adresse de la mairie et j'ai
un interlocuteur public qui me guide de
A à Z entre le diagnostiqueur référencé
l'artisan les travaux le guichet unique
qui va traiter tout ça entre ma prime
renve le C2E et ce aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué donc moi j'avais appelé de mes
vœux aussi à ce qui est l'expression
doctolib est pas la bonne mais qu'on ait
une plateforme unique digitale qui
permette d'avoir l'intégralité des
acteurs de A à Z avant après du
diagnostiqueur à l'artisan référencé et
ce et puis dernier sujet de ne pas
oublier le monde financier des banques
parce que ce sont les banques qui
financent
l'immobilier en France et à l'étranger
les banques ne prennent pas d'hypothèque
parce que si elles prenaient des
hypothèques si vous prenez une
hypothèque sur un bâtiment G si
l'emprunteur fait défaut vous n'arrivez
pas à le vendre donc vous vous
sousceriez vous prendriez soin pardon de
savoir si le bâtiment est passé de G à C
parce que s'il y a un défaut vous le
vendez quand il est sa bon donc je pense
qu'il faut arriver est-ce que c'est par
la réglementation est-ce que c'est par
l'iniit commercial des banques est-ce
que c'est par d'autres choses est-ce que
le monde financier accompagne cette
transition énergétique parce que
l'épargne des Françis est très
importante mais ils n'ont pas forcément
tous de l'épargne et tous envie de la
diriger à 100 % sur le donc voilà moi ce
serait ça un petit peu ne changeons pas
le dispositif il est pas parfait mais il
existe avançons à toute vitesse sur les
bâtiments publics et privés et il faut
que les bâtiments publics soient
exemplaires et qu'on change d'ord de
grandeur et tr ne pas oublier d'avoir
des mécanismes de financement c'est
quand même la tuyauterie de base qui
soit aussi fluide et performant que
possible Antoinette Gul
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur oui moi ma question va porter
sur l'économie circulaire vous en avez
beaucoup parlé pendant pendant cette HE
7h30 d'entretien
euh en fait le secteur d'activité que
vous représentez c'est 75 % des déchets
en France 75 % c'est donc énorme et vous
voyez que dans la question non seulement
du du traitement des déchets mais de
l'économie circulaire et bien vous êtes
un acteur principal en tout cas l'enjeu
que vous représentez est principal dans
l'économie circulaire vous nous dites
qu'une grande partie des de vos produits
sont aujourd'hui des produits
recyclables donc ça je l'entends vous
l'avez expliqué fait à partir de
matièrees recyclé moi ma question c'est
combien aujourd'hui de vos produits sont
recyclés parce que c'est ça en réalité
qui aussi est important il faut bien
entendu qu'on puisse qu'il puisse être
collecté qu'il puisse être traité et en
fait ce recyclage est aussi votre futur
enfin représente aussi votre gisement de
futur matière première il me semble
quand même quand vous dites on ne peut
pas être devant chaque chantier pour
faire la récupération quand vous dites
on fait des accords avec les
collectivités locales et cetera ça me
semble un peu léger parce qu' il est de
votre responsabilité parce que c'est
votre gisement futur mais parce que
aussi c'est de l'intérêt général dans
votre j'allais dire dans votre secteur
d'activité de s'assurer en fait d'avoir
une bonne collecte de ces déchets de ces
déchets de chantier d'avoir une collecte
qui soit organisé dans toute la France
et mettre ça sur le dos des des
collectivités publiques dont ça n'est
pas la responsabilité ça me semble voilà
un peu léger je pense que là il y a un
travail à faire vous avez raison la re
va arriver et c'est un travail qui va
être fait dans ce cadre là enfin donc
j'imagine qu'à partir de du début d'
l'année prochaine on aura une autre
une autre forme de discussion mais moi
ça me semble un sujet extrêmement
important une deuxème question sur votre
le verre plat que vous produisez zéro
carbone donc vous avez vous vous l'avez
expliqué en introduction il y a une
production de verre plat zéro carbone ce
qui en soi est une bonne nouvelle si
aujourd'hui on réussit à faire du verre
sans aucune dépense de carbone ça relève
même du miracle donc j'aimerais plutôt
savoir en réalité il s'agit doute d'une
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour produire ce verre d'autres
produits
d'autres
approvisionnement en matière première
donc ça vous l'avez un peu expliqué et
en réalité d'une baisse des émissions
carbone pour la production de verre et
non pas du zéro carbone comme le dit
cette communication voilà et puis enfin
je j'avais une dernière question sur
l'impact sur la santé mais bon c'est ok
on arrête là
merci Madame la signatrice pour vos
votre votre question je pense qu'il y a
il y a un terme en tout cas nous on
essaie de le le changer c'est de parler
de déchets justement parce que il faut
qu'on arrive à dire non c'est des
matières premières voyz le terme déchet
de la M façon qu'on il faut qu'on change
l'image du monde de la construction
parce que oui on peut très bien vivre
étant artisan c'est un très beau métier
ça améliore le bien-être de nos villes
de nos concitoyens donc le terme déchet
il faut qu'on le bannisse moi je le
bannis en interme parce que non mais
parce que il faut qu'on le valorise
déchets c'est quand même bon mais c'est
purement peut-être une astuce de langage
mais je pense que symboliquement c'est
c'est important parce que précisément
c'est une banque de matériaux vous avez
raison de dire le bâtiment de demain et
d'aujourd'hui c'est une banque de
matériaux et donc il faut le valoriser
voilà c'est juste un parce que c'est
important dans et vous avez raison aussi
de souligner dans le monde d'ailleurs
j'ai pas en tête le chiffre de 75 % en
France mais dans le monde c'est 50 % des
des volumes de matière solide c'est le
monde du bâtiment alors nous on avance
beaucoup sur ces sujetsl la bonne
nouvelle FO encore une fois c'est que
c'est c'est 100 % recyclable on mesure
pas parce que nous quand on recycle des
matériaux que ce soit du verre ou du
plâtre on s'en fiche de savoir si c'est
du ver saint-gobin du verre a les
japonais où on prend tout ce qui vient
donc je peux pas vous dire parce qu'on
met pas une puce rfidé sur le vitrage
pour que selui qui a été installé il y
avait pas de pucefidé il y a 40 ans
quand on la mairie de Paris démonte une
école aujourd'hui on se dit ah c'était
du vers bas on le prend ou c'est pas du
ver 5 bas on le prend pas nous on est
très agnostique on prend tout ce qui
vient en terme de matière parce que la
masse est importante et alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour investir là-dessus j'ai
j'ai indiqué hein on a déjà initié ça il
y a 4 5 ans euh avec un dirigeant de
saint-bin qui a fait le plus beau
éco-organisme de France on a mis à
disposition on est les seuls dans le du
NGOs de matéau à avoir 300 plateformes
partenaire de valobat pour précisément
au plus près des chantiers oui mais on
peut pas avoir moi j'ai 38000
collaborateurs en France je peux pas les
mettre au pied de chaque chantier pour
attendre le PVC qui descend la laine de
verre euh c'est c'est pas notre métier
ça veut pas dire que ce qu'on fait c'est
c'est de mettre des big bags nos
artisans quand ils viennent sur un point
P le flux physique c'est ils savent
qu'il faut recycler ils savent qu'il y a
une une agence nord de Bordeaux qui a
toutes les déchetteries sur place avec
les tris des différentes Benes et on
leur donne les huit big bags qui vont
mettre au pied du chantier et on envoie
des camions pour dire quand le big bag
du plâtre est prêt on vient le chercher
parce que c'est pas l'artisan quelque
fois qu' le ramène quand le big bag du
PVC est prêt on va le chercher et cetera
donc on est en plein partenariat avec
valobat avec la massification de la
présence de 520 on a aussi beaucoup
investi dans nos propres usines si je
prends la plaque de plâtre on est à plus
de 20 % de matière recyclé on a investi
sur une nouvelleal de recyclage à vos
jours sur un atelier de recyclage aussi
à chambée donc des silos de recyclage
donc parce que la matière recyclée bah
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on préfère la
mettre dans un silot pour la mélanger de
la matière vierge pour contrôler la
stockiométrie et apprendre petit à petit
donc on a beaucoup d'investissement à la
fois physique dans nos 300 négoces que
j'évoqué et on a 2000 en France donc moi
je souhaite qu'ils soient tous capables
de faire ça donc on avance à toute
vitesse le le ver zéro carbone que
j'évoqué c'est du verre zéro carbone
scope 1 et 2 qui a été fait pas scope 3
c'est une première mondiale donc moi je
suis plutôt fier que ce soit saint-gobin
qui l' fait plutôt que des Américains
des Chinois des japonais depuis parce
qu'elle était 100 % avec du verre
recyclé et 100 % avec du biogaz
malheureusement on peut pas avoir 100 %
de verre recyclé partout en France parce
qu'il y en a pas assez parce qu'il faut
aller chercher ce verre recycler et donc
oui moi je trouve que c'est quand même
une bonne idée de signer des accords
avec la Mairie de Paris pour leur dire
non on est capable de prendre tout ça
voilà comment ça va s'organiser et
sachez que ça existe plutôt que chaque
artisan qui improvise sur tel ou tel
chantier donc on va continuer de monter
en puissance et depuis cette production
zéro carbone qui était un peu moi je
voulais symboliquement frapper les
esprits en disant c'est possible c'est
pas un mur technique on sait pas faire
du ciment zéro carbone et après on a
quand même fait une offre commerciale
avec 42 % de CO2 en moins parce que
c'est 70 % devent recycler mais si on
peut faire 75 % deain parce qu'on a plus
accès à de la matière on le fera et et
on voit vraiment ça comme une banque de
matériaux pour les les années qui
viennent Christian Redon Sarasin oui
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur général je vais
revenir sur le sujet des déchets même
s'il a déjà été largement évoqué puisque
vous êtes un c'est le bâtiment c'est un
secteur qui qui en produit beaucoup que
ce soit dans la démolition dans la la la
production des matières premières ou ou
dans la la construction elle-même qui à
chaque fois est générateur d'un certain
nombre de ces sous-produits euh leur
réduction c'est un enjeu majeur que ce
soit pour des raisons de coût des
raisons environnementales moi moi ma
question c'était même si vous avez déjà
en partie répondu mais je je
souhaiterais quelques compléments quells
sont donc pour saint-gobin les grandes
innovations attendu en matière de
d'organisation en matière de Red pour
aller vers cette réduction des déchets
et et êtes-vous sur un même niveau
d'exigence dans vos activités à
l'internationale et notamment dans les
pays à bas coup de mainœuvre ou dans les
pays du Sud que ce que vous
avez présenter sur effectivement le le
territoire
national l'innovation comme j'ai indiqué
c'est un de nos cas quatre piliers
l'économie circulaire c'est un des
quatre piliers de l' rité de saint-gobin
on dépense 550 millions d'euros de
recherche et développement par an donc
c'est un des quatre et à point important
donc c'est c'est vraiment un axe très
important de savoir comment on récupère
des matériaux comment aussi on va
chercher d'autres matériaux décarbonés
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure sur le
silicate de calcium donc il y a tout un
tas de recherches sur ces sujetsl pour
décarboner la formulation et également
baisser le poids des
matériaux aux États-Unis la plaque de
plâtre elle est à
5,6 kg 6 kg du mèt carré en Espagne elle
est à 9 parce que les artisans Espagnols
les normes espagnoles veulent que ce
soit dur et pas léger la plaque légère
elle a la même performance donc on
travaille aussi avec tous les organismes
de certification parce que quand vous
baissez de 25 % le poids de la de la
plaque de plate avec les mêmes
performances bah ça fait autant de CO2
en moins donc il y a tout un tas de de
recherches sur ces sujetsl et partout
dans le monde on a les mêmes exigences
alors après il y a pas les mêmes
réglementation par exemple aux
États-Unis ben nous on force nos équipes
à recycler la plaque de plate alors que
la mettre dans une décharge au milieu
mil de l'Arcana ça coûte rien donc on a
les mêmes exigences moi j'étais en Inde
toute la semaine dernière on y a même
conduit le conse administration de
Saint-Gobain qui a passé du vendredi au
dimanche soir bah oui on recycle et on
est les premiers à organiser très en
amont les filières de recyclage de
calcin j'aiindiquéis tout à l'heure on a
pris des participations minoritaires
dans des filières de recyclage de verre
au Brésil pour aider ces activités à se
recycler alors il y a pas encore dans
ces pays beaucoup d'activités de
démolition parce qu'on est encore
beaucoup dans la construction neuve
alors qu'on est plus dans la
réhabilitation ou la la rénovation en
Europe mais oui on a les mêmes exigences
après les réglementations sont pas
toujours les mêmes donc on est en avance
de phase et au-dessus des réglementation
mais on pousse ces sujets là partout
dans le partout dans le monde pierre m
deeveille enfin il reste
encore merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur directeur général merci pour
votre exposé vos réponses claires bravo
pour vos
résultats moi ma question est plus
technique j'étais j'aiété invité l'an
derniè avec quelques collègue à au
climtech de TelAviv qui est un salon de
d'adaptation technique nouvelle au
changement climatique et un ingénieur
nous a présenté une maison énergie
neutre ça me paraissait assez judicieux
puisqu'elle était fabriquée de panneaux
vides creux panneaux isolant bien sûr
certains étaient plein d'eau d'autres
plein d'huile rempli avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur le toit bien sûr bon
l'été ça ça refroidissait l'eau qui
refroidissait la maison et l'hiver ça
chauffer l'huile qui chauffait la maison
c'était entièrement neutre et ça
fonctionne il paraît très bien donc je
voulais savoir si vous avez entendu
parler de cette technique et si vous
étiez intéressé par ce
processus monsieur le sénateur la
réponse est non je n'ai pas entendu
parler de ce de cette activité là à
TelAviv après il y a il y a encore une
fois la capacité on a d'ailleurs un
démonstrateur depuis plusieurs années à
côté danger à beaucousé une maison
passive sans aller jusqu'à des
innovations huile eau euh
comme vous l'évoquiez on a des maisons
passives aux États-Unis en Allemagne en
Suède en France il faut mettre la façade
au nord de telle et telle façon il faut
mettre les cellules sur le toit il faut
faire un puit canadien dans le jardin il
faut isoler l'enveloppe je l'ai déjà
évoqué ça fait une maison passive qui
produit plus d'électricité qu'elle en
consomme donc on sait faire et avec de
l'isovert que vous achetez chez
pop positif voilà du double vitrage bas
émissif avec l'isolation des Combes
voilà tout ça c'est possible enc une
fois le le le monde du bâtiment et c'est
une chance la solution technique existe
elle est accessible et elle est pas
accessible à 5in fois le coût bon la
difficulté bah c'est de faire des
millions de chantiers c'est de former
des centaines de milliers d'artisans
c'est d'avoir du financement c'est
d'avoir des permis de construire c'est
d'avoir des architectes qui sont désirer
de le faire c'est d'avoir des bâtiments
publics y compris historiques qui
bougent dans la bonne direction et
cetera donc la difficulté pour nous
encore une fois c'est plus l'agrégation
de la chaîne de valeur plutôt
conservatrice parce que les artisans ils
s'engagent sur une garantie décennale
donc il faut que lui l'au ne se mélange
pas dans 3 ans et dans 5 ans pour mais
Pau séparé non mais après si vous faites
un trou pour accrocher votre tableau
est-ce que ça fait fuir le je sais pas
non mais voyez y a deux trois donc nous
la difficulté c'est pas tellement la
réponse c'est pas tellement la réponse
technique c'est la mise en mouvement
d'une chaîne de valeur qui est par
nature très fragmentée et l'effet
d'échelle sur des millions et des
millions de logements de par le monde
alors on va peut-être partir autre mare
avec Micheline
jacqu
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur les travaux de la délégation
sénatorielle aux aremèes ont démontré
l'inadaptation des normes du BTP dans
les territoires ultramarins bien que ces
territoires représentent un marché
réduit ils sont de
véritables laboratoire de recherche et
d'innovation dans un contexte de
réchauffement climatique par ailleurs le
rapport reconstruire la politique du
logement outremè a préconisé la une
promotion de l'architecture
bioclimatique basée sur des savoir-faes
traditionnels et sur l'utilisation des
richesses naturells des Ares mers tels
que la brique de terre cuite compressée
à Mayotte la brique de terre cuite en
Martinique le pain Caraïb le bombou la
Bagas le wapa le gayak pour ne citer que
que ces quelques exemples je rappelle
aussi que la filière bois en Guyane est
en plein essort avec 1,4 million
d'hectares gérés par l'ONF je voudrais
savoir quelle est la place des outremèes
dans votre stratégie de développement
non
carboné nous n'avons pas un sujet
spécifique sur le le TR et je m'en
excuse en revanche on a pas mal
d'activité effectivement
sur des pays à environnement chaud et
humide donc ça peut pour certains pays
d'outrem s'appliquer et on fait aussi
pas mal de choses sur le le le
bioclimatique ce que j'aiévoqué sur sur
la construction en terre crue en en
région Provence ALP Côte d'Azur bah
typiquement ce que vous évoquez sur la
construction terre crue traditionnelle
avec peut-être des capteurs ou des
mesures modernes d'aujourd'hui c'est
c'est une réponse tout à fait judicieuse
don donc je pense qu'il faut avancer
là-dessus et effectivement dans le monde
du bâtiment comme sur les sujets des
carrières profiter du savoir-faire local
profiter des ressources locales plutôt
que de copier des réponses qui sont
valables dans dans d'autres pays donc je
je pense que en économie circulaire
comme en savoir-fire de construction et
en ressources naturelles il faut faire
avec du local et retrouver parfois des
savoir-faires ancestrux qu'on a un peu
perdu ou un peu négligé Yve
bleuven merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général pour vos
différentes explications trois questions
rapides qui sont sur le même fil rouge
votre côté visionnaire comment vous
voyez l'évolution des matériaux dans les
prochaines années on sait que depuis
quelques années la crise du logement
s'installe de façon grave en France et
que les multiples dans les multiples
facteurs le coût des matériaux
représente un coût non négligeable de de
de l'exlication de cette crise la
deuxième chose vous avez une vision
mondiale de la norme de la
réglementation des lois partout dans le
monde si vous deveniez donner un conseil
à nos gouver ou à nos législateurs sur
la façon dont la France produit de la
norme et du
législatif donnez-nous des conseils et
dernière chose
4700000 logements sociaux en France dont
plus de 70 % qui sont construits avant
1990 beaucoup de passeoir énergétiqu
avez-vous imaginé avec l'ensemble des
bailleurs un plan Marchal en matiè
de rénovation d'innovation avec des
idées peut-être là aussi qu'on a pas
nous pour l'instant
imaginer alors sur le sujet coût des
matériaux c'est vrai qu'il y a eu de
l'inflation parce qu'il y a eu de
l'inflation énergétique je l'ai évoqué
en introduction le coût de l'énergie
chez saint-gobin la facture énergétique
était de 1 milliard elle est de 3
milliards donc ça a triplé et si je
prends le verre bah le verre il y avait
en temps normal 30 à 35 % de coût
d'énergie c'est monté jusqu'à 85 % donc
on ne peut pas sauf à passer
oui mais si vous voulez l'inflation
énergie matière premières chez
saint-gobin elle a représenté en moins
de 18 mois 5 milliards d'euros dans une
année normale de saint-uebin il se
trouve que saint-bin s'est beaucoup
transformé parce qu'on a simplifié
saint-uebin on l'a organisé par pays
donc il y a eu énormément de changement
de Saintin et un/3 du périmètre de
saint-bin a changé en 5 ans et on a
beaucoup investi en Amérique du Nord
beaucoup investi en Asie mais on s'est
beaucoup transformer je pense que pour
s'améliorer il faut se transformer on a
beaucoup beaucoup transformé
Saint-Gobain avec une centaine
d'acquisition i une centaine de sessions
et un tiers du périmètre donc 14
milliards qui ont changé en l'espace de
de 5 ans ça explique les résultats de de
Saint- gubain mais dans une année
précédente on avait 3 milliards de
résultats 5 milliards d'inflation si on
faisait rien on mettait 5 bain en perte
en 9 mois et 2 ans après on mettait la
clé sous paillasson donc oui on a dû
malheureusement monter les prix des
matériaux alors comment on l'a fait on
l'a fait en accompagnant beaucoup les
artisans on a prévenus les artisans on
était le seul à le faire et moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de discussions même avec Bruno
Le Maire qui dans l'observatoire de la
construction voulait que les autres ares
acteurs F comme saint-gobin qu' ont
donné 2 mois de préavis on faisait des
devises fixes chez pointp vous faites de
la rénovation vous êtes allé chez
Monsieur Bazin pour faire un devis de
rénovation vous passez les commander
matériaux les prix n'ont pas changé et
tr on fait un milliard et demi de crédit
gratuit aux artisans 1 milliard et demi
de crédit gratuit aux artisans
aujourd'hui si vous voulez vous financer
auprès d'une banque soit vous n'en
trouvez pas soit ça vous coûte 5 6 ou 7
% nous on fait 1 milliard et demi de
crédit gratuit aux artisans donc tant
mieux que saint-gobin aille bien parce
que son bilan est solide et finance le
de la construction en France puisqu'on a
90 % des artisans de la capB en compte
qui ont 20 30 50000 € de découvert chez
Sainta à taux zéro donc c'est très
important parce que oui il y a de
l'inflation sur les coûts des matériaux
sinon malheureusement l'histoire de
Sabin aurait été beaucoup plus compliqué
alors le coût des matériaux dans un
chantier ça à peu près 30 % donc quand
les matériaux montent de 10 % ou un peu
plus bah ça fait 3 ou 4 % de hausse
c'est désagréable et c'est important
peut-être que ça va se tasser il y a
plus d'inflation d'ailleurs sur les
matériaux cette année parce qu'il y a
plus tellement d'inflation au sens large
mais le degré 1 encore une fois c'est le
coût de financement quand vous passez de
1 à 5 % de coût de financement vous avez
perdu 25 % de votre pouvoir d'achat donc
là aussi débat discussion sur le sujet
du du financement est-ce qu'il faut pas
être un petit peu plus souple un petit
peu plus créatif sur le sujet des
financement déduction des taux d'intérêt
on l'a fait à une certaine époque
déduction des taux d'intérêt sur la
rénovation énergétique enfin il y a
quand même beaucoup de d'outils je
rappelle que le monde de la construction
il rapporte 100 milliards nets à l'état
donc si on veut se dégager des marges de
manœuvre quand vous prenez toutes les
taxes et les prélevements de droit de
mutation plus la TVA sur les chantiers
de rénovation c'est 100 milliards net
pour l'État si d'ailleurs le monde de la
construction va moins bien ça fera des
recettes fiscale en moins mais c'est 100
milliards nets des aides sur le sur le
logement donc il y a de la marge de
manœuvre si on veut aider la principale
composante d'inflation qui est le
financement et le coû de financement du
logement alors les les meilleures
réglementations thermiques on a beaucoup
de choses dans les pays nordiques dans
les pays nordiques si vous voulez on a
une parfaite isolation de la maison
triple vitrage et ceeter on en est même
faire de la ventilation parce que un
sujet qui va venir ce sera quand même la
qualité de l'air et quand vous avez bien
isolé pour pas avoir d'humidité il faut
faire de la ventilation donc dans les
pays nordiques nous on fait 500 million
d'euros d'activité de ventilation donc
c'est quand même les pays nordiques qui
sont plutôt en avance mais la re220 en
France est très exigeante et et très
bien elle est plutôt précurseur par
rapport à beaucoup de pays d'Europe
continentale donc il faut pas
s'autoflagéer sur le fait que la France
serait en retard le dispositif DPE est
très bien la re220 est très bien mais là
aussi ne la changeons pas parce que il
va falloir 10 ans pour mesurer l'impact
dans des centaines de milliers de
chantiers et sur les parties logements
sociaux les logements sociaux ils ont
l'avantage d'avoir des bailleurs sociaux
qui sont capables de raisonner retour
sur
investissement ils ont des financements
Caisse des Dépôts nous on leur procure
par exemple sur des grandes barres de
HLM on fait des photos avec des drones
3D de la surface de la façade du HLM on
prédécoupe en usine les carrés de laine
de verre parce qu'on fait l'isolation
par l'extérieur les habitants restent à
la maison hein contrairement à ce qu'on
nous dit parfois pour l'isolation il y a
pas besoin d'envoyer les gens à l'hôtel
donc ne faisons pas l' isolation parce
qu'il faut mettre les gens à l'hôtel
fait l'isolation par l'extérieur sur les
barres de HLM et avec des carreaux
d'isolation prédécoupés en usine pour
gagner du temps sur le chantier donc moi
je suis moins inquiet sur la partie
logements sociaux dès lors qu'on y met
du financement et je suis content que le
le ministre du Logement a apporté je
crois dans le Congrès des HLM la semaine
dernière un financement complémentaire
je suis moins inquiet sur la partie
logements sociaux que sur la partie
maison individuelle petit logement
copropriété copropriété changeons les
règles de copropriété on sait rénover
les ascenseurs tous les 5 ans avec des
normes sur les ascenseurs bah faisons-le
sur la rénovation énergétique des
copropriétés c'est là qu'il faut
fluidifier le système avec des guichets
uniques alors vraiment la toute dernière
question Lucien stenionne non tu es
alors
vite merci Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général oui parce qu'il se
trouve qu'avec la présidente on a des on
a eu des activité en commun sur le
logement social effectivement logement
social sur le logement social ou c'est
suffisant c'est
suffisant comment ça et c'est souvent là
que les choses innovantes se déroulent
d'ailleurs parce que on manque de moyens
et donc on est plus
inventif ma ma question j'aurais aimé
aussi qu'on puisse échanger mais le
temps étant passé sur les
constructions de type naturelle puisque
il se trouve qu'aussi on est du même
pays et que ces questions de terre cuite
et tout ça c'est intéressant donc
simplement ma question c'est autour
de des des élus locaux vous en avez un
peu parlé tout à
l'heure quel serait pour
vous le moyen
d'accompagner les élus locaux dans cette
démarche que vous avez expliqué de de
gain sur les économies
d'énergie est-ce que vous pensez que
votre entreprise peut être moteur au
niveau des des élus et si oui euh avec
quel outil à mettre en place voilà je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur je pense effectivement que les
élus locaux parce que fondamentalement
le logement la construction c'est par
nature extraordinairement local ont un
rôle très important à jouer au plan des
communautés communes pour bah engager
des acteurs de la Fédération du bâtiment
ou de la CAPEB pour cibler dans une
communaité de commune un quartier qui a
été construit à peu près dans les mêmes
dates et pour dire voilà euh euh si on
fait ces rénovations dans ce quartier de
5000 maisons individuelles est-ce que
j'ai un peu de marge de manœuvre sur les
taxes foncières pour dire une fois que
vous serez rénoveré de F à B vous avez
un avantage fiscal ou en tout cas je
peux mobiliser des artisans pour dire
ces 5000 maisons on va massifier un
petit peu la rénovation parce que les
les les solutions de rénovation seront
les mêmes on va avoir un guichet unique
local qui permet de canalyser tous les
dispositifs les diagnostiqueurs les je
pense qu'une une une région une communé
commune peut aider à identifier et à
former les diagnostiqueurs les les
accompagnateurs de rénovation engager
des artisans donc je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup d'initiatives locales c'est
comme ça qu'on le voit qui peuvent
prendre masse et ce sera plus facile
qu'au plan national certains réussiront
d'autres iront plus vite d'autres un peu
moins vite mais je pense que d'ailleurs
c'est ce que pousse je crois le ministre
du Logement c'est de territorialiser ses
actions parce que les réponses ne sont
pas les mêmes les tissus sont pas les
mêmes et il y aura des initiatives et
des expérimentations très fortes nous on
a des démarches en qu'on appelle Renault
bâti en ce moment dans la région Est de
la France en Occitanie également qui
sont intéressantes dont on peut vous
transmettre les des exemples qui sont
justement de cibler des rénovations
massives sur des quartiers avec des
collectivités locales je pense qu'il y a
il y a un rôle moteur à
jouer Monsieur le Directeur Général de
saint-gobin merci merci du fond du cœur
pour le temps que vous avez consacré à
notre commission et à l'ensemble des
commissaires puisque vous aurez passé
avec nous 2h30 de votre temps et on
imagine combien votre emploi du temps
est un emploi du temps extrêmement
chargé donc merci de ce temps que vous
nous avez consacré vous avez pu voir à
travers les nombreuses questions
foisonnantes de l'ensemble des
commissaires combien les commissaires de
la commission des affaires économiques
étaient motivés combien aussi il
disposaient d'une expertise souvent
ancré dans leur propre territoire et je
crois pouvoir dire que vous avez
nettement à travers vos propos aussi
enrichi leur leur expertise merci merci
du fond du cœur pour la clarté de vos
propos pour leur pertinence merci merci
aussi pour la performance de votre
entreprise et comme l'a dit Laurent
Duplomb nous sommes très fiers de votre
entreprise de saint-gobin et nous vous
souhaitons encore bonne chance et
beaucoup de réussite dans tout ce que
vous entreprendrez merci à très
bientôt madame la Présidente merci
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs merci infiniment
merci